This is Jocko podcast number 86 with Echo Charles and me,
Jocko Willink.
Good Evening Echo.
Good evening.
And it has been a little while since we got down to some Q and a.
Sure.
And on top of that,
on the social media,
I have not been as responsive as I normally am.
I've had to prioritize and execute a bunch of other things,
things like muster things like books that are due,
things like that.
So,
and a bunch of travel and a bunch of work with echelon front,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
So,
but I do get the questions,
I read the questions I read that I read.
If you post something and you tag me in it on Twitter or you put a comment on
Instagram,
I read it 100%.
Yeah,
I read it.
But lately and normally I would like everything that I see.
Sure.
I would like it just,
just so you know,
hey,
I saw her down.
Yeah,
I'm here.
I heard you.
But lately I haven't been able to do that.
Dang.
So,
so I've just been,
I read it,
move,
read it,
read to move.
Uh,
but if there's a good question comes up,
I copy it,
I paste it,
I put it in the,
in the question bank.
And then when we get to do a Q and a,
we answer the questions that I think either they get asked a bunch,
you know,
so I've seen a question four or five times that type of question.
Yeah.
Or just a unique question that I think a lot of people can benefit from and
that's where we ended up with.
So today Q and a.
And let's rock and roll.
First question,
I do want to add that on Twitter,
both throw seed also,
you know,
you say you like everything,
you know.
Yes.
Certain things,
sometimes they don't necessarily warrant like you liking them,
they require an answer,
you know,
like you can't like that.
Like let's say someone has this like really trying time or something and they
say something or whatever and it's a question like,
hey,
how do I get through this?
You can't dislike it and move on.
Okay,
I can do that.
So what I do in those situations is I like it.
I copied the question and I put it in the question bank all.
Okay.
So you're like,
is my like,
has various meanings in my life does not mean like,
yeah.
Yeah.
My like means received.
Gotcha.
Yes.
Yeah.
And it,
and,
and it is a heart,
which I vehemently disagree,
disapprove of,
and disagree with.
No,
no.
Come on Bro.
Come on.
No,
no hearts juncos world,
right?
Yes sir.
So,
well,
I do.
It's my way of saying I read it,
but what I'm saying is it's saying that I'm ready.
I'm telling you that right at this,
the past,
like week,
I've read everything.
I always read everything,
but I haven't
even liked him because I haven't had time to start liking them.
Dang.
Yes.
Because if I like it,
that tells me that I've gone through it and if I had to pull something from it,
it's how I keep track of what I've read and what not,
just what I've read.
It's how I keep track of what I have extracted pertinent information from.
Yeah.
I might have to start doing the opposite.
Only like something if I want to go back to it.
Oh yeah,
like a bookmark.
Yeah.
Maybe I'll start doing that anyways.
If you're out there,
I'm reading your messages,
your tweets,
your posts.
Right.
I appreciate it.
It's all good feedback.
It's awesome.
Yeah,
but sometimes you get yours,
you're in the initial post,
we'll say and maybe I'm in there,
maybe some other people and then other people chime in.
Then it starts to morph into this conversation between two other people.
You can't really like those necessary.
I usually do,
but just to keep track of where I am.
Just like,
oh yeah.
See like the bookmark it to bookmark.
So this you talking right now is just one big mass like you guys saying,
hey guys are ready.
Here it is.
You're less.
Yes.
I like you like you all.
All right.
We're not even,
I like you all cause some of your comments I don't like.
Yeah,
I still like them though.
Yeah.
Verb like yeah.
I like a press,
like even though you said something and I don't agree with,
so I still,
I liked like back that you expressed yourself.
So even if I hate what you said,
you still get a little heart.
There you go.
They should have one that's an eye look,
a picture of an eye.
Like I've seen this.
That's what it means and all right.
Right.
And I have a ball.
I saw this,
he saw this.
And then you could say like,
and you should have a thumbs down.
Dislike.
Yeah.
Look on Youtube.
Either way.
There you go.
Alright,
first question.
Hey Jocko.
I'm a 35 year old and have a physically demanding job.
I've been a dry Waller for about 14 years.
Work about eight to 10 hours a day.
When it comes to working out,
I'm finding it really hard to maintain discipline to continue as it seen as it
seems.
I burnout also have two boys under the age of four,
so I sleep like you do.
I can relate,
man.
Yeah.
I'm wondering if I'm just being a pussy and need to push through the burnout or
take a different approach to working out when I burned out,
my buddy just feels weird as well as my head.
I tend to get depressed and find it hard to even go to work.
Just throwing this out there for maybe some tips to get over this so I can stay
focused and consistent.
Thanks.
Cool.
Okay,
so hanging drywall.
Have you ever hung drywall before?
No.
Yes.
No late.
Okay.
I better know what the answer means.
I've been in a dry wall hanging scenario scenario.
Yes,
but I didn't do the pain of the,
okay.
Yeah.
That does not qualify as it beat Bro.
You do not get called for heavier drywall if you seen it being hard.
I appreciate what you're trying to say,
but that doesn't work then you can.
Dry Wall is hard work.
Yes sir.
It uses a bunch of different muscles in your body and of course when you get
better at it,
cause I'm not good at it.
When I,
when I hung dry,
when I hang drywall,
if I'm doing a project,
I'm not good at it.
If you see someone that's good at,
like this guy that's been hanging drywall for 14 years,
he's a master.
He's,
he's holding one hand slapping nails him.
He's or dry wall screws on stilts.
Guys work on stilts.
You ever seen that before?
No.
So good drywall.
They're on stilts because they don't,
they're just boom,
slap it up there.
So,
but it's hard.
You're doing,
you're basically doing a clean,
kind of pull the drywall up,
you're pushing it up or you're using your grip strength and the drywall.
Then you're doing overhead presses cause you dry wall ceilings sometimes.
So,
and it's eight to 10 hours plus,
not to mention you're,
you're bending down picking stuff up all day.
So it's eight to 10 hours of squats,
cleans and overhead presses with grip work.
So you're doing that eight to 10 hours a day.
So you're getting good physical work throughout the day.
Now look man,
if you're that drained,
then first of all,
let's check the Diet.
Let's make sure that we're not on the job site and the donut truck arrives and
you're,
you're going belly up to the donut truck with a monster for monster energy
drinks.
Like to keep you going through the day that's going to hurt you.
So check the Diet.
It's the good thing is check a diet and then if you have to just bring your
food,
don't let you know your bro that's going to run down to Mickey D's to grab lunch
cause you didn't pack anything that's going to jack you up.
So all that stuff will make you feel weak and out of sorts and all that.
That being said,
it's still,
you're working hard all day.
You're doing hard physical labor all day.
You also,
I mean you can see construction workers were dry drywall as you can see people
that are due that hard labor all day and they don't look like they're in shape
right there.
Maybe their fat,
maybe they're just,
they don't look like they're in shape.
Well that's cause their diet sucks.
Generally they're coming home and they're getting on their,
their 12 pack of beer and pizza.
So get your Diet,
make sure your dad's going to go.
And then what I would do is,
and I've worked construction before and or even big projects on my house where
I'm working all day long remodelling pulling down drywall,
putting up drywall,
demo in rooms,
whatever.
Uh,
I still do work out.
Now what you're going to do though is do something that is going to compliment
what you've done during the day.
So you're getting some pretty good strength work at this point.
You're getting,
you know,
you're getting cleaned,
your work,
you're doing all this,
this hard work all throughout the day.
So maybe what you need to do is do some more cardiovascular at night or maybe
it's just like a really good stretching routine cause you got your strength and
you got your cardio do during the day.
Like if I think about how much I sweat when I'm working on a house project,
I'm going to full athletic sweat.
So that means I'm working hard.
So find what can you do that's going to compliment the,
the conditioning that you're getting from your actual labor.
And maybe in your case it might just be like straight up mobility.
It might be straight up mobility.
Like hey,
you're just doing some good stretching,
you're doing some MobilityWOD.
That's mobility workout of the day.
You can go to that website.
They got really good stuff on there to to loosen up and make sure you're staying
limber because another thing you find with construction guys is they end up with
some,
you know with a bad back with a bad,
they get,
you know,
tendonitis from swinging a hammer all day or holding it so you can get those
kind of use overuse injuries and yeah,
so I would look at what you can do that's going to compliment that.
Also,
maybe you feel like maybe you just need to do some heavy lifting because you're
lifting something little all day.
You know who you're lifting drywall all day,
so you're getting some good endurance,
muscular endurance,
but maybe just come home and do,
do a couple sets of heavy dead lifts are a couple of sets of heavy squats.
And the other thing here is like when we're on deployment,
when I was back in the,
in,
when I was in the military,
when we were on deployment,
we wouldn't be doing workouts that are going to give you the,
the four days of delayed onset muscular soreness,
right?
You're not going to hurt locker is you're not going to put you in the pain
locker where,
hey,
I did squats yesterday.
Oh,
echo just got shot.
I can't help him too tired to sword broken.
Someone grab echo cause my legs were super sore.
My quads are hurting from front squats yesterday.
So that's not what I'm talking about.
I'm talking about doing some something that's heavy,
but it's quick and you're not,
you know,
you're not going crazy and doing so many sets that you're going to build up all
kinds of lactic acid and make your legs all sore.
So maybe it's something that,
but I would say explore all that.
Look what you can find that's gonna make you,
that's going to compliment what you do at work.
And also you could look some Jujitsu,
you know,
look at some Jujitsu,
Jujitsu.
Although at first it's a crazy muscular workout,
a full body workout like you've never had before because you're resisting every
part of your movement and you'll be sore your entire body.
But then as you get better at it,
you can relax more.
That takes like a year,
year and a half,
maybe even two years before you can really start to relax.
The thing that's cool about that for you is you've got two kids under the age of
four,
so maybe in two or three years they're ready to start training to now you've got
to get something to share with them.
A little bit of the Jujitsu,
so yeah.
Don't kill yourself.
Find something that compliments your work.
And if that's just stretching,
Ben,
just stretch.
Yeah,
and maybe you don't.
I used to do it,
uh,
when I was a team to team tea,
we sued,
we used to run all the time.
It was every day.
It was like,
oh,
Monday,
PT in Iran,
Tuesday swimming around Wednesday,
obstacle course,
and Iran,
Thursday,
I forget what it was.
And then Friday was a long run.
It was like a 12 mile runner,
10 mile run on Fridays.
So what I would do is I would get done with work on Friday or get done with a PT
on Friday and usually we'd be like half,
half day frogman Friday.
Sure.
Strongly on Friday.
Get some pre war,
no war going on.
Guess what you do on Friday afternoon and the trims you're going to go,
you know,
get after it with your boys
in the bar and the bar.
Sure.
Yeah.
Frontline Friday frogman Friday again frogman Friday kind of went away once
September 11th happened,
so,
but this is pre September 11th frogman Fridays.
So we get done with work at know noon and I would just Friday go down and hit my
squats and then so Friday I'd heal up Saturday and Sunday back to work on
Sunday.
Ready to rock and roll.
Yeah.
So maybe you hit just do a good workout on Friday.
Good hard workout on Friday.
He'll up over the weekend.
You're feeling good Monday back in the game.
But yeah,
hard labor.
Yeah.
Requires something a little bit different than those of you that are sitting at
a desk looking at a computer screen like Echo Charles.
Yes sir.
Yeah.
You can do different kinds of workout when you do that all day for sure.
You mentioned the Diet.
I would say with 99% certainty,
I would say I don't know everybody.
Right.
I understand that 99% certainty that if you have a good day and not even have
immaculate a good diet and you're working drywall construction moving as I used
to be a mover for a little bit.
Yeah.
If you have a good diet,
I mean you watched moving cause apparently in your mind that qualifies for,
you know it just total victory.
Yeah.
Anyway.
Oh I know you were an actual yeah,
but I wasn't the best mover.
I was one on one.
Anyway,
that's a,
that's a whole nother thing anyway.
If you have a good diet and you're doing this kind of work,
that is your workout essentially,
and it's a long one.
It's probably a hard to work out than most people's normal workouts you do.
And that's the thing.
You're so right because when you're working eight,
10 hours a day,
there's a lot of work to be done.
So your lunch break is like,
Dang,
this is,
I'm going to go to get some delicious,
you know,
to this food truck right here or this,
and will wherever,
wherever it's not,
you know,
but you get a good diet with this kind of stuff.
You essentially have a great workout along with a good diet.
You're going to get results.
Just that.
And in a way you won't even really have to do these supplemental workouts unless
you have different goals.
So if you're like,
okay,
I'm just going to do my work,
I'm going to have a good diet,
and then I stretch afterwards,
which is such a good idea when you call day,
same motion all day,
stretch,
you know,
get all that.
But you'll be way better.
You'll way better to him.
You'd be surprised how,
how much easier the work becomes with that diet.
And also maybe there's,
like I said,
you need to look for what compliments it.
Yeah.
So with dry wall,
I don't,
I don't know.
You know,
it's probably not dead lifting cause you left lifting stuff all day,
but maybe it's just like some hardcore,
uh,
like Ab core strength that you're going to work.
You're going to,
you know,
and that's going to strengthen your lower back.
It's going to offset all the pressure that you put on your back all day.
So maybe it's that,
maybe it's,
you know,
pull ups because you're not really pulling yourself up.
So maybe you're doing two workouts.
Maybe we're doing like one workout on Fridays.
You do an abs and pull ups and then during the week you're doing a 20 minute
stretch session to really make sure your hips are opened up.
Right.
Of course,
like them guys from 10th Plan as Uga.
It's got to be flexible.
They're flexible.
That's the,
you have to be,
you have to be able to do Lotus to get your black belt from Eddie Bravo.
There you go.
I can't do the Lotus.
I can't get my black belt from Eddie Bravo.
No,
no,
no.
You can't.
No,
sorry bro.
I should be able to do that at some point.
Depends on what you mean by should,
but yeah,
man.
Cool.
Do the Lotus and then work on that and you know,
report back.
But yeah,
the Diet thing,
I think the Diet thing that's going to be 75 if not more personal people,
he'll be up there.
You,
they say,
Oh,
you don't sleep enough and how do you not see,
don't eat crap.
You don't need as much sleep.
Yeah,
check that out.
Give that one a try.
Yeah.
And listen,
let's face it,
there's people can be different with requirements.
Seriously.
You know,
like if I said,
Hey Jocko,
you're in prison for,
I dunno,
whatever.
And you have eight hours of sleep for eight hours.
I don't know if I can do that.
Deployed on a ship multiple times,
three shipboard deployments as a seal.
And when you're a seal on a ship,
you have no job.
You don't like the guys that are the guys that are in the regular navy that are
driving the ship and maintaining this ship and steering the ship and all that.
They have a job.
We have no job,
eh.
And so what we could either sleep,
eat or Lyft and that's a race to say seal stood for sleep,
eat and lift.
But some guys would sleep a lot.
I wouldn't sleep a lot.
You get some guys that had to like sleep disorders.
There was a guy that slept for like 29 hours,
but they need to wake up and stay awake for 32 hours and then he'd go back to
bed.
So yeah,
it was kind of weird.
His circadian rhythm was way off.
Yeah.
And then that happens too on a ship because you can stay inside the ship with no
sun for forever if you want to.
We used to,
we used to go out as much as we could on the deck of the ship.
Yeah.
Get a Sun Tan,
do PT.
Sure that too.
But yeah,
I think you,
yeah,
you sleep different and you know,
some eight hour in,
actually I've done the thing where I got used to only getting like six,
six and a half and it,
it started to work.
Like I said,
you know,
I didn't like that.
I tried to go back to,
actually I only get six,
maybe seven though anyway.
Cause the kids thing anyway,
the Diet,
I think we'll,
I prefer real thing.
I believe this be a fact.
75% or more solution to the whole problem.
The diet clean up the Diet is good when your lunch.
Yeah.
Stay away from the Mickey D's.
Stay away from all that stuff again man.
That's,
that is hard to consider it.
I mean I know it's hard to because you were tired.
It's a cycle that you started going down.
Yeah.
Because you were tired when he got home so you didn't make any food for the next
day.
So that means you brought something crappy or you bought fast food and now you
hate the fast food,
which makes you feel bad,
which means to get home.
You're tired from genes,
you don't make lunch for the next day,
which means you're only in this bad cycle.
And that's not to mention the pleasure part of it.
Cause like this hard work.
I need some relief from this hard work.
Work on my lunch break.
Dark chocolate.
Yeah.
Maybe bring some chocolate milk.
Yeah,
it tastes good and it's good for you.
Well are equally,
we'll say arguably it's not as bad for you as a mountain dew or a pizza by the
slice from the truck.
The food truck.
Yeah,
and that's usually what it is,
man.
Take it from me.
I know.
All right,
cool.
Next question.
That was one question.
We're 20 minutes deep.
Amen.
We got to get to the bottom of these things.
I think that'll help though.
There will think so because look,
if you,
if let's say,
if you think,
oh yeah,
maybe I'll change my diet,
but you know what?
Okay,
I'll,
maybe I will.
Maybe I won't.
I'll just kind of focus on the workout part of it.
Yeah,
Bro.
You Bet.
Man.
One time I was like,
uh,
I didn't do any cardio.
I just kind of lifted and whatever.
My Diet was not all that and Churros I was being strong.
I went to the doctor,
they said,
your your cholesterol,
our thing,
you know,
some stuff on the inside.
I was super unhealthy.
He was like,
you're unhealthy.
I'm about being in strong.
I was like,
wait sir,
but I can bench a lot.
I'm like,
Bro,
that doesn't matter.
So you can hang dry wall all day,
all day and Dang,
that's some good endurance.
If you can do that all day,
every day for 14 years,
by the way,
and be like,
oh,
I'll unhealthy because you ate wrong.
He had all Jameel that bat clean up the Diet.
Yeah,
it's good news is clean up the Diet pill situation.
Next question.
How do you,
how do you install pride back into an individual and ultimately a battalion?
I'm on my 17th 17th year serving in the British army.
I've been in my role for about a decade and I'm about to move on to different
job.
Recently I've came out of my platoon bubble and notice there are numerous issues
I've identified and I'm looking to help my coc in fixing it.
All right,
so you want to instill pride back into a battalion,
into a unit,
into an individual.
Uh,
in my opinion,
pride comes from hard work.
Pride comes from discipline.
Pride comes from performance,
and pride comes from winning.
And how do you win?
You win from hard work,
you win from discipline,
so that's the cycle.
You work hard,
you stay disciplined.
That makes you start to perform.
That makes you start to win.
When you start to win,
you get pride and of course there's a dichotomy there too because you can work
your guys too hard,
right?
You can do that so you have to balance it.
Then it's funny actually,
Leif was talking about this I think,
I don't know if it was a,
we were with a company and he was saying when we formed up task unit bruiser
we worked hard.
We worked a lot harder than normal tasking.
It's worked.
We stayed later at work.
We came in earlier and you know he was saying,
Hey,
when we first the first like month we were together and and jock was God,
everyone coming in early and all this stuff and people are grumbling about it
and why do we got to do this extra stuff and he's,
he's like,
yeah,
there's people are grumbling about it.
But then once we started going through training in our performance was above our
peers,
then all of a sudden it turned from grumbling to like pride.
So that's the,
then the guys,
they stopped complaining and they start bragging because you know what?
Where do you bruiser yeah,
of course you're not at work cause you're,
you're tasking you to is weak.
We are strong,
you are weak.
Get away from us.
We don't want to be associated with you.
So you start getting that,
which is pride.
So I think that's what you've gotta do.
You've got to instill the hard work,
the discipline in your team.
It will hurt a little bit at first.
You got to make sure you don't go overboard with it and that'll get you what you
want.
If you need further references on that,
read a book called steal my soldier's heart by Colonel David Hackworth or read
about face by Colonel David Hackworth.
He talks about this,
does he takes the takes battalion,
his battalion in Vietnam with no pride and turns them into people with a ton of
pride.
How does he do it?
Makes them more card.
Makes them have disciplined and then they take pride in what they're doing.
Lead by example.
Yes.
Anne Hackworth.
He doesn't change everything at once.
He hasn't come in and just go crazy.
He starts changing.
Important small things a couple of day,
Huh?
I think literally he says two a day.
We change two things a day.
But he did start off with a big thing.
If you remember this,
he checked in this battalion,
guys have radios,
guys have guitars,
guys have little bars set up.
They got all this crap and he goes,
hey,
everything that you can fit in a rucksack tomorrow morning in the middle of the
compound here and we're getting rid of it.
So that was a big wake up call for everyone.
But it was a,
it was a wakeup call.
And also it was,
why are we doing this?
What?
We're doing this so that we can move when we move.
We won't get hit at night,
we'll get hit at night.
We won't lose anybody.
So
good stuff.
Makes Sense.
Next question.
Sorry for the English.
I'm French.
That's a disclaimer.
Hmm?
How can a man that has not grown up with the confidence and trust Ding male role
models and mentors,
sort of anti uncle Jake persons only intellectual.
I'm saying this without districts or disrespect to these people.
How can they become a confident man and develop the necessary man skills,
quote unquote.
Okay.
It's interesting that you can say man skills in quotes.
Yeah.
And I think we pretty much know what that means,
right?
Yes.
Like we know what that means.
So how do you do that?
You don't have any positive role model around you.
That's I can uncle Jake,
which by the way,
most people don't have an uncle Jake.
Yeah,
right.
That's not normal to have uncle Jake.
Most people you got what you got.
And in this case he's saying he's got like the intellectuals.
So you know,
my parents were college professors and they don't have any of these skills and
they sit around and talk about philosophy.
Right now I ended up,
I can talk about philosophy.
Well,
but
I can't fix my car or I can't defend myself in a combat scenario in the streets.
So what are you gonna do?
Okay,
this is a real symbol.
Go do things.
Lift,
start lifting weights,
learn how to dead lift.
Learn how to squat.
Yeah,
that's a,
that's part about being a man,
right?
Sure.
Physically strong,
physically strong.
Learned some Jujitsu.
I recommend that.
Probably could have guessed that one.
Learning how to fight,
learning how to defend yourself.
I just got asked this the other day.
A kid came up to me,
he's like,
what should I do if I get intimidated by other people and I or I don't know how
to react when people like get in my face and I said,
do you train Jiu Jitsu?
No.
Start trying to Jiu Jitsu,
but then what?
I'm going to find everyone.
No,
no,
no.
You don't have to because you already know you can beat him up right now.
If they attack you.
Yeah,
you can beat him up.
But if they are just getting in your face and try to punk you and you look at
them and go pay,
if you want to do this,
let's do this,
but I don't care.
I know you can come to my gym,
I'll choke you out.
Trained some Jujitsu.
Uh,
so we got that one.
Run,
hike,
sprint,
climb,
build things,
start building things,
rewire things.
Okay,
do some plumbing.
These things are not
there.
They're not impossible to do.
Now it's going to take you longer.
Right?
Like I've rewired my parts of my house,
I've re plumbed parts of my house and done all the plumbing and parts of my
house.
Now if you watch a skilled electrician do what I'm doing,
he would literally take him one eighth of the time,
maybe one quarter of the time because,
or like the dry wall or we were talking about earlier,
a good dry Waller.
They are like masters,
a good electrician,
masters,
a good plumber.
They're smooth me.
It's going to take a while.
Sure.
So,
but,
but what I'm saying is it's not impossible.
It's not impossible to do and it'll take you more time,
but you're learning how to do it and that gives you,
what does that give you?
It gives you the self-reliance,
right?
Hey,
I can fix my electrical outlet if I need to.
So those are good things that work on your car,
change your oil,
whatever,
do those things.
And again,
those things like I,
so I took electricity class in high school where we learned how to wire rooms
and everything cause that what it's called,
it was called electricity class.
I took electricity with Scotty was the teacher's name.
Sure.
Wait,
you called him Scotty.
Everyone called him Scotty.
He was an older guy.
His name was Scotty.
We all called him Scotty Sweeney.
So Scotty,
but we,
we learn how to walk wirehouses and all that.
Well,
I didn't remember any of that when I was now 20 years later or 15 years later,
I'm a rewiring my kitchen where I,
which I ripped out of my house.
Okay.
So what did I do?
You know what I did?
Went down to home depot.
I bought a book called electrical wiring and I've read through it and I'd
followed the directions.
Same thing with plumbing.
Go down by a book called how to do plumbing and you do it and it,
and the,
the good thing about this stuff is it's very satisfying to do that kind of work.
It's very satisfying to do it.
And you can over engineer things,
you make things super solid in your own house.
Super Secure.
Super.
Yeah.
You can just kind of go the extra distance cause it's your own,
your own house.
So that's cool.
Uh,
so those are all physical things and some kind of knowledge things that you can
start working on.
What all the hardest thing to overcome here is like a level of embarrassment.
Yeah.
Right.
Like,
uh,
I don't know anything about wiring.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
You know,
I don't,
I'm embarrassed to say I don't know anything about wiring and so people don't
want to say anything.
So they'd rather just say,
hey,
let's get an electrician in here to figure this one out.
Or Hey,
I will just get,
yeah.
So they're to too embarrassed.
But if you have time,
do it yourself and don't be embarrassed about it and be like,
Hey,
I'm more,
I'm rewiring my kitchen.
And I have no idea what I'm doing.
Give me this book,
what I need to get.
Oh,
give me some tools.
It's good to have good tools.
Uh,
also.
So that's,
that's like I said,
those are things that you can do,
you know,
um,
learning to shoot,
you know,
learn to shoot.
That's a good,
good skill to have.
Also read,
write,
read about history,
read about survival,
read about the world,
read about human beings under duress,
read,
read books,
good books about good stuff,
about challenges.
It's,
and then just like mark way,
the warrior kid,
he doesn't know his times tables.
He has to learn them.
You have to go learn all this stuff I'm talking about.
You have to go learn.
And with,
with time your confidence is going to grow.
And from humility you'll grow into being more confident.
Now you also say you don't have any mentors or role models around you.
That's okay cause those mentors,
mentors and role models are in books and you can find them.
I just talked about David Hackworth,
good mentor to have.
Imagine you can have a guy,
a guy wrote you a 1000 page book on how to lead and is for you.
That's pretty awesome.
Beyond Band of brothers,
by Dick Winters.
Guess what?
Here's a guy that was the in charge of
the
band of brothers in Normandy and he wrote a book for you to learn how to lead.
So those are some examples.
And like I said,
most of the books that we've covered on this bar,
many of the books that we cover on this podcast and give you a mentor better
than anyone could possibly hope for.
Yeah.
So you can get it there,
but,
and,
and we mostly cover war books,
but there's books about all kinds of people that can be virtual mentors.
So read,
study,
Do,
do,
that's my advice on that one.
Yeah.
That physically strong thing is,
uh,
in my opinion,
a big deal because especially what with um,
you know,
intellectual types and that kind of environment since that's not really a
priority,
a lot of the time
youth tend to,
you know,
how like you're not into something,
so you kind of shun it as adults.
And I've seen this,
I'm not saying all the time,
but you know,
sometimes the don't take downs so I'm not going to do them.
And then you think of all the reasons why you don't need to do it and how guys
focused.
True.
You know,
or whatever.
So in intellectual circle,
we'll see those circles.
Sometimes he'd be like,
Oh yeah,
those meatheads or whatever,
you know,
they just,
they'll shun it.
You said about that issue
there?
Yeah,
maybe.
No,
I don't think so actually.
Yeah.
But they'll do that and then there'll be these for physically frail people,
but since they,
they're in their mind smarter than everyone,
they feel like that the one up in there kind of,
there's an element of satisfaction there.
Yeah.
But
at the end of the day,
you're physically weak when it comes down to it.
And I think most of the time I think,
I don't know.
But it seems like most of the time they'll have these feelings.
Like this guy asked right here,
like,
yeah,
man,
how can I develop?
Because I feel it.
Yeah.
Unless they just want to be in denial.
That's what exactly what,
but when you're in also,
and by the way,
the same thing happens in the reverse,
right?
Yeah.
A guy that's just a meat head,
he shuns and and disrespects or disregards the intellectual side of things and
that is the,
that is equally as bad because they're not,
they don't know what's going on.
They're not knowledgeable,
they're not learning,
they don't understand the world in a clear way.
So find the balance between those two things.
Yeah.
What's great is those things are not mutually exclusive.
Like you don't have to just be a meathead or just have to be a book warm.
Right.
You can do both.
There's plenty of time in the day to do both.
Be a smart ass guy with a big dead lift.
That's a good thing.
I'm trying to be that guy.
Not there yet,
but I'm working on it.
Yeah.
And then that one level up,
which is the Jujitsu part of it.
You did nothing to you.
I'm thinking about who combines the intellectual piece with the physical piece
and in a way you can kind of,
I would,
I'm not recommending this at all.
In fact I'm against this,
but this is the nature of Jujitsu.
You don't have to be that.
Like you don't have to have a big dead lifted two dominate in for sure.
Don't have to do any of that.
So you can essentially overcome the physical part of it even though just the
physical,
but it's a,
you don't have to,
you're going to overcome the physical part of it for it to a point.
Yeah.
In everyday life.
I mean you,
you're trying to,
you're trying to be the fill guy.
Like if someone's better than you at Jujitsu training room,
it really bothers you or he's talking about everyone or are you just talking
about me?
It doesn't bother me.
Well,
let's say it motivates me.
I don't know.
Like it doesn't bother me.
I mean,
like for instance,
I trained with Dean lister all the time.
Yeah.
He's better at me in Jujitsu.
Right?
I every day want to train with them so it doesn't bother me.
Says,
not bothered,
but like what an no compels you like,
you know,
well maybe it does.
Like I hate it at the end of the day.
Depends on what you mean by a lot of them.
I hate it.
I do.
I hate it and I love it.
And we were just joking about the other day cause we got new little scrap
yesterday,
you know,
kind of end the training and all of a sudden things got escalated and there was
some shouting going on and shouting,
shouting,
you know,
he was saying what he says and I was saying what I say and uh,
but we had a know we had a mutual truce at the end.
I think he didn't really want any more.
I didn't really want any more.
So we just Kinda said let's,
let's laugh and call it good cause you're,
you're rolling the dice.
When I'm rolling with Dean,
there's a,
there's a dice roll happening.
Cause if he ends up in a good position on me,
there's going to be paid.
There's going to be pain.
If I ended up a good position on him,
there's going to be paid.
So I think both of us,
we got away a little bit of an escape.
Neither one of us got a really good position and we,
I got back up to my feet and I,
and then we both kind of just had a mutual agreement,
an unspoken agreement that we were done for the day
that happened.
But
the point there being is in a host,
like in this weird way,
you know how like intellectually you can excel so you can kind of find it
justifiable to avoid the physical part of it.
It's almost like you could almost say the same thing about Jujitsu.
You could still be effective in defending yourself without be physically strong
necessarily.
But,
but my point is that there's a limitation to that.
Ultimately you can be,
you can be unbelievable at Jujitsu,
but if you're really,
really weak and you go against someone that's really good at Jujitsu,
but there are a hell of a lot stronger than you,
you're going to have some issues.
Right?
Right.
Yeah.
And that goes for everything.
You've got to be both.
Yeah.
I ideally,
and that's ultimately the main point is just like how intellectually you can be,
you know,
a black belt and you can sorta in a way get away with not necessarily being this
as a way of holding people and vice versa.
And then do you do things like that third element you didn't sort of get away
with not being super strong but still be effective in Jujitsu.
You know what I mean?
So yeah,
ideally just,
yeah,
get,
get that balance.
But being able to defend yourself is a whole nother thing than being physically
strong at,
you know,
seems obvious.
But when you go through life,
I think it's not because you get these like big Jack guys and it's like no one
wants to mess with him.
Well Bro,
this medium to small guy who knows Jujitsu or knows these,
you know,
for real fighting stuff is way more of a,
I don't want to say dangerous,
but yeah,
ultimately way more dangerous than this big jacked guy who can lift a lot for
sure.
So it's that third element that are kind of like weird when your role with
somebody that's super jacked and they don't know Jujitsu.
Yes.
It's amazing.
It was amazing.
Yeah.
You just think to yourself,
how was this happening?
Yeah.
This is the magical power.
Because you looking at a big Jack Guy,
your human instincts tell you look out,
he's going to fat person is stronger than you,
you know,
watch out.
But when you know Jujitsu you don't,
and eventually you realize you don't even have that anymore.
Yeah.
You know everyone you're looking at thinking,
wait,
you don't have,
oh you don't have
the instinct of fear.
Although you're still you,
you know,
my first thought when I look at someone was like,
do they train or not?
Yeah.
Do they train or not?
If they train we,
we may have issues.
This could be a problem if they don't train.
No factor.
No train,
no factor.
Yeah.
If they train may have a factor.
That's why I got to work out harder,
so I'm going to be strong.
Yeah.
You know,
you know,
cause they might be coming to take my lunch money maybe.
Right.
I don't want that.
Oh,
how's this last night?
Literally last night.
Do you even train last night?
I did not train last.
This is a real world experience.
So you know the five gallon jugs of water,
you know those big when you put it in the water cooler or whatever.
So there's like a little refilling thing that I went too late.
It was like,
no,
I've told this story before.
Now there's another,
this happened last night.
Hey soul hazardous duty know refilling it.
Yeah,
I know.
Okay.
I mentioned I do that.
So last night when I was doing now was refilling the jugs.
Um,
you know,
I go in the store,
I'm coming out walking to my truck to get the empty jugs to go to the little
thing.
As I'm walking to my truck,
a car pulls up right next to the water feeling thing.
There's a,
what's called a red box.
You know what that is?
It's a DVD rental thing.
Yeah.
So carpals up a kid,
maybe 12 years old,
jumps out of the car,
he starts like he's a normal kid,
whatever and from in the car,
this male probably is dead,
someone maybe Stepdad really.
And immediately the dad starts yelling at him like just put it in the thing.
And just to the point where I thought it was kind of joking where cause all joke
in my daughter like that he kind of like how you'll do sometimes.
Yeah,
you'll get in.
It sounded like a joke,
but I was like probably this guy's serious.
And the kid is like,
you could tell he was kind of used to it.
He was like,
I am,
I'm doing,
I'm trying,
you know,
whatever,
whatever.
And that kind of the whole parking lot could here,
and this is at nighttime just to give you the setting.
So I'm walking to my truck,
I'm like,
Bro,
if I get to this place and this guy still there,
not even yelling,
I'm sitting there,
I'm going to have to say something,
not be a Dick,
not be like,
hey,
like that,
I'm going to try to solve this problem and be like,
Hey,
this kid,
you know,
whatever.
I had this little thing before I knew Jujitsu or anything like that,
I wouldn't have messed with it.
I would even been like big or whatever,
and Shawn,
I would've been like,
aw man,
that's all I've ever known that guys got going on here.
Yeah.
You know?
But man,
I was like,
man,
I'm going to do this.
So I grabbed it and they left.
So I didn't get the opportunity.
But I'm just saying,
these are things that can happen on varying levels every day.
And if you're an intellectual tech,
and I'm not saying if you're an intellectual,
but if you don't have these elements of whether it be skill or knowledge or
whatever,
like those things mess with you.
You know,
you're like,
I can't get to.
And when I figured out what did you do was when master chief,
Steve Bailey choked me.
And he was,
he was an old man at the time,
probably three years younger than I am.
And I was thinking to myself,
this is how this guy just do this to me.
That's insane.
That's completely insane.
I need to learn whatever he knows,
teach to me,
whatever,
you know,
cause I don't want to feel that way ever.
Bra.
And then you're training it like let's say you train for five years,
for five years,
your training,
not against people who don't know.
You're training against people who do not dangerous people who do know how to
defend your shit and then you go in the real world.
Yeah.
You have this guy has no idea how much control you have over and you didn't even
touch it.
Yeah,
I see.
that's totally.
So again,
this whole thing where,
I mean you're in,
you're thing about,
um,
some guy with the guy was,
his problem was like when people get in his face or whatever,
his problem wasn't getting beat up.
It was when people get in your face and how you react and how you feel and
stuff,
but that feeling gone.
Yeah,
because you're right,
you're,
you're 100% right.
Because he said he wasn't scared
of fighting.
He was saying like I might get in trouble.
He was,
he didn't like how we felt.
He felt like he should do something and he felt like a wimp basically.
When you know that you can destroy someone and then it doesn't matter,
you just think they're an idiot.
Yeah.
You beat them.
You get the strength and the skills and you actually beat them on an
intellectual level,
so it's like a dance.
Double Gravitational.
All right.
If you can get those three and an intellectual,
psychological,
whatever,
mental,
physical and skill wise,
defending yourself,
probably that's three right there.
It's good stuff.
Not just how hard you want to hit it.
Really.
You want to hit it hard?
I think so too.
You know,
it's very beneficial to hit it hard.
Next question,
Jocko.
Could someone always be detached?
Okay.
Straight forward question.
The answer is no.
Someone shouldn't always be detached because otherwise you aren't enjoying
anything
in your life.
So don't always be attached,
detached.
No.
But at the same time that being shared,
you should be all aware all the time.
If you are getting sucked into the emotional vortex,
right.
You've gotta be aware of that.
Once you have that awareness,
you don't need to be attached all the time at all.
Yeah,
you can.
I'm not always detached at all,
but,
but I've got clear warning signs when things start going sideways and I started
going down some vortex.
I know immediately and I just detach.
So it's really easy.
It's,
but it's,
it does take practice and eventually you realize that you know,
when you're feeling overwhelmed,
when you're feeling emotional and you're feeling angry or you're feeling
frustrated,
when you start feeling those things and you've sent them really quickly and you
recognize them,
you just attach,
boom,
you're done.
So that's what you gotta do.
Start recognizing those red flags so that you can enjoy the good things.
And when something starts getting crazy,
you can detach.
Yes.
So it's like an overall skill of being able to control when to detach and when
you don't have to.
Being able to identify when you need to detach,
then being able to detach then you're good.
Yeah.
So it's like it's a matter of being capable of making an accurate,
beneficial choice.
Yeah.
The identification is the hard part.
What happens to people when they talk to me is they go the after the fact they
realized I lost my temper and I did this.
Okay.
You didn't detach it in time and that's why you ended up there.
So,
or I said some things to my,
you know,
my ex girlfriend that I shouldn't have said because I got too emotional.
Exactly.
You didn't detach and tongue,
you got crazy and emotional.
So the skill that you're missing is identifying when you're starting to get too
emotional,
whatever that emotion might be.
Once you identify it,
boom.
Detach.
Yeah.
It's kind of like control.
Then you can take control.
Yes.
And make tactical moves,
not emotional moves.
Ultimately that the art,
you know,
to make the move.
You know how like did you two guys be,
if they never take anything?
No.
You know what,
the moves,
when you're emotionally detached,
the moves actually aren't that hard.
They're actually usually pretty obvious.
Like you're,
you're in a fight with your girlfriend and,
and you're starting to go down the wrong lane.
As soon as you did that,
you go,
oh,
I know what I need to do.
I should say I'm sorry and tell her that we can go to the restaurant that she
wants to go to or whatever.
You know what I mean?
The,
the,
the moves are not actually that hard,
but we never make good moves when we're being emotional.
Instead we just go,
no,
I don't want to go to that restaurant.
We went there three weeks duel.
I don't care if I'd said that to you.
You deserve me to say that to you.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
That you go down the wrong path.
But what if somebody like detached the whole time,
even when problems don't arise like that and then we don't have a relationship.
Right.
That's what I mean.
That's,
yeah,
that's what I'm saying.
So it's sort of,
you're not being to detach fault all the time.
That's what I got to the answer to the question.
Right.
So it's like you've reiterated it for everyone.
Yeah,
man.
That's what I'm here for.
I think a lot of times,
you know what guys will ask you,
Hey,
I want to learn to get to,
I want to learn to mess people up.
I think bro,
that's not really what it is.
Did you get to,
is having the skills to quote unquote mess people up.
But what you learn ultimately is you put yourself in a position where you can
make that decision.
Is it time to mess someone up or not?
You know,
and you just have control.
So that's really what most people that start with the vision of,
I want to build a mess people up.
Most people continued that,
that do continue on the journey of Jujitsu,
arrive at a point where they realize that they don't want to abuse this power
that they now have.
Yeah.
Most people,
yeah,
there's a small percentage of people that don't,
that are bullies.
They were bullies when they started and they become more effective.
Bullies.
More fearful,
more,
more fear in posing beliefs.
Yeah.
Which sucks.
But Jujitsu is power.
That's where you're going to have some of it.
Yeah,
I agree.
But compare it to like a,
I dunno anything where it's like striking based or whatever.
It's like you,
like I've said this for,
I'm not going to go deep in it,
but you go from zero to 10 when you throw a strike that's already at 10 know.
You can't just throw a light one and be like,
okay,
are we going now?
You know,
kind of thing goes.
They're not cool.
Nope.
You slap me in the face.
We ain't cool at all.
He brought it to 10 where the duct amount of nuts.
It's funny because like I see,
I see my kids and,
and what you're talking about can happen very easily when other people are in
the group.
With my kids,
I mean because they've been training Jujitsu,
so even like against any normal kid,
there's no factor.
Yeah.
Like I see me to my song will be wrestling around with some kid has no factor.
And it's,
you know,
it's kind of cool.
Kind of cool.
It's real cool.
Yeah.
You know,
my kids aren't like Jujitsu,
like there's kids out there that are sick,
competitive Jujitsu all the time.
Yeah.
Right.
Huh.
That's not what I'm talking about.
Like just knowing Jujitsu
a hundred percent correct.
Yes.
And but when I see kids doing Jujitsu specially like,
I'm not saying it's necessarily even in a tournament,
I'm just saying in Jujitsu,
in class,
even at the beach or whatever.
When I see him,
I'm like,
man,
I wish I could have done Jujitsu when I was a little kid.
You don't find that would be men.
Make up for it now.
Try it.
Next question.
Jocko.
I'd been offered a job as a deputy sheriff of a few months before the position
is actually open.
I really want slash need to get into some Jujitsu due to the nature of the job.
The closest place to me is over an hour.
Drive away.
Yeah.
Harshel finances are an issue when it comes to that kind of drive plus fees to
attend.
My main question is how do you feel about Gracie's online school?
That's an option.
If I were to find others who want to learn,
would this be effective?
Uh,
yes.
So here's what you need to do.
Get some mats.
You can make mats,
you can get,
you can get a piece of canvas from home depot or a piece of vinyl and string it
between trees on the ground.
You just have mats.
You just made them all over grass.
That works.
I've done it.
I've trained on,
there's a truck called a six by in the military.
It's a big giant,
like a truck.
And it has,
you've seen,
this isn't like your typical war movie.
The truck with the canvas tarp over the back.
Rambo.
I've taken that thing off and that was my mat on top of the truck.
No,
no,
no.
Taking it off the top of the tree.
You took the canvas and that canvas,
I'll put it on the ground.
Guess what I got now?
Jujitsu,
Matt.
Strong wooden stakes in the ground.
We're going to go to canvas,
but it's good to go.
So you do that.
Then you get on youtube,
you know,
Youtube,
you know Gracie Academy,
uh,
Marcello Garcia online.
Those are really good.
I would actually start with youtube,
just like get some basics down and get some fundamentals get you'd need two,
three,
four friends.
If you got a friend that wrestled,
get him in there.
If you got a friend that did judo,
Um,
and then you just start looking at the moves and fighting each other and trying
to see what works and don't go nuts on each other.
Trying to figure out what works,
what doesn't work,
learn the basic concepts.
And then maybe Saturdays,
maybe every other Saturday,
maybe one Saturday a month,
you drive an hour to the school with your buddies.
You go in there,
you say,
hey man,
we live up in wherever,
an hour away from here.
If we give you 10 bucks,
can we get on the mat?
You know,
this weekend just for just for a couple hours,
can you,
can you look at what we're doing?
Maybe even say,
Hey,
look,
in the four of us,
get a private,
we'll all give you 20 bucks.
That's 80 bucks.
You can make an an hour coach,
please.
So then you get some detailed training and that's going to give you a base.
You know,
that's I think your best option.
Yeah.
Fully these,
um,
online,
uh,
you know,
academies
and stuff,
that's essentially what they're made for.
If you can't make it out of me,
you go to the academy.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
And I think podcast number six,
we talk about what to look for in a Jujitsu Academy.
Yeah.
So go back to podcast number six.
If you're starting Jujitsu and you want to find a good academy,
go back to podcast number six.
Yeah,
it's in there.
fully in,
I think to start,
especially if you don't know,
do you do through it all?
I like,
I think a lot of us started,
you did too with watching UFC one,
two,
three,
four,
you know,
so we kind of,
after watching that,
we kind of see,
okay,
I see if your mount,
if you have mount,
that's good.
If you're on the bottom card,
if you,
you know,
so you got to pick up.
I didn't,
I knew what Jujitsu was,
so I didn't get to experience trying to learn the basic moves from seeing owner
UFC.
So I'm taking what you're telling me as factual and it makes some sense.
But so did you actually like compute that the positions you were like okay
that's the guards.
So you must have watched in detail.
He wants to watch where you might be like,
okay that Guy Hoists Gracie,
that guy that's wearing that white thing,
that white uniform,
look what he's doing.
He's got his legs closed run like I,
that's where you guys were doing essentially.
But cause even the announcers weren't calling it guard back then where they uh,
yes,
there was a guy who was real nerdy guy and he was those Yossi too.
I want to say maybe even what,
I forget which one was which.
But yeah,
he,
he knew and you could tell he was like kind of prideful that would train with
and whatever.
But if you've got,
so you know how he's going to pull them in between his guard,
but he knew and he go,
well,
okay,
he's going to mount.
And it was real repetitive because he'd do the same thing.
So yeah,
you,
you essentially,
if you're paying attention,
you learn guard.
You don't learn how to do an Armbar.
How did you know?
Well,
when I teach kids,
sometimes I'll just say,
you want for like,
let's say a kid has been training for a day.
So first day you want to keep your legs around them,
right?
Yeah.
That's guard.
They don't even know what they're doing.
And then you say the other kid,
you want to get away from there or get around their legs.
Yeah.
And so they just try and do it.
And that's a pretty cool way to start things off.
Very.
You'd be surprised at what kids will instinctively do to make things happen
there.
And you,
even at the muster,
you know how you explain it just real quick.
Like you're okay,
this is amount is why it's important.
This guard,
that's why it's important.
That's really like the other day,
um,
ad there was a new girl in there.
Her name's Sarah.
I remember that cause I know someone else named Sarah.
But anyway,
uh,
Adam,
it was time to roll round team and say,
hey there.
Adam was like,
hey,
you know,
there's some new people here.
Smash,
no days,
zero days,
whatever.
Um,
experience,
can you,
I dunno,
teach or something,
you know,
as a rounds are on,
cause I didn't have a partner at the time,
came in late or whatever.
But so I went and I did essentially that just sort of crash course.
This is mount,
this is guard,
this is a side mouth,
you know,
and this is the importance of each one.
And then this is literally takes five minutes.
So let me,
here's the importance of everyone.
And then I do a little quiz at the end.
I said,
okay,
boom,
we fight.
It's like half speed.
We fight,
boom,
we fall to the ground.
Where do you want to be in the,
you know,
so it's like a little quiz and boom right there,
that five minutes you learn everything that I learned from watching UFC one,
two,
three but two,
we're studying them and you were trying to figure it out.
But yeah,
you can learn it in five minutes from somebody shown it here.
Exactly right.
If that's what they're teaching you.
A lot of times people will go in on their first day and some,
some academies,
they're dope.
They'll have an introductory class class.
It was just kind of have that,
it's called introductory class.
But if you're like,
hey,
this is my first day,
let me see what I can learn.
Then they'll learn like some,
um,
you know,
almost plot or something and they're like,
wait,
whoa.
I don't know how this even make sense to me,
you know,
but if you learn that crash course,
um,
or you know,
even going to muster,
that's why it's so cool.
You,
you go over that and I was like,
Dang,
this is cool.
You can leave that and now you're way better off.
Everyone has heard us talk about Jujitsu,
so they have this anticipation of it being really cool and then when they
connect the dots between like,
okay,
you learn the mount and then you learn the guard and then you learn the sit up
sweep and when you done with the setup sweep here,
you're from the guard,
you're back in the mountain and people were like it.
It's a miracle.
It's a miracle man testers,
the magic,
you know it and it's essentially before the actual moves,
like doing the moves.
It's just you have to know what's important and what's not.
Like if you mount on someone just by happenstance,
you don't know what mountain is or the importance of pump,
but if you wind up on the mound,
you're trying to punch the guy.
I'm saying in a fight you're trying to punch the guy and try and do damage.
Trying to win the fight,
but punching the guy is not what you should be focused on.
Primarily.
It should be keeping the mind the position.
Exactly right,
but no one's going to automatically know that that's not,
you know,
you're trying to beat up the guy.
I'm on top.
I can punch him,
let me punch them.
But no,
it's just one of the many examples.
Next question.
Jocko.
My boss is incredibly controlling an eagle maniacal.
I like him already.
EGOMANIAC.
I have,
I have attempted to use extreme ownership in dealing with the people under me,
but my boss has reprimanded me for leading.
He has said he gets,
he gets to do all the leading because he's the one in charge,
quote unquote and,
and his job title is higher than mine.
I've had that happen to me before.
By the way,
if I could continue to try to lead,
my responsibilities will be taken away.
If I stepped back into the shadows,
I won't make an impact on the people under me.
What should I do?
So it's black and white.
Yeah.
Right.
And his mind seems that either step up and lead and get fired or step in the
shadows and do nothing and everyone will suffer.
It's not,
it's not that way.
Right?
It's not.
It's not black.
And White and actually start by putting your own ego in check because you're
calling someone at ego maniacal,
but you're,
your ego is being,
being touched a little bit here,
rubbed the wrong way a little because
you want to lead.
And when you get told don't lead,
you get paid and offends you.
Guess what?
That is your heat.
That's your ego.
So what you need to do is maybe you like the,
you like the feeling of being in charge.
That's cool.
I liked the feeling of being charged.
It's,
it feels good to me.
It feels normal to me when I'm not in charge.
I don't like it.
I have to consciously suppress it,
which is fine.
Sometimes you have to do that like right in this situation here that this guy is
talking about.
And what you need to suppress is you need to not be so overt with your
leadership.
He shouldn't even be able to sense that you're leading,
but you should be leading.
You gotta be under the radar.
You gotta be covert with what you're doing.
And by the way,
while you're doing that,
you're massaging homeboys,
ego.
Make him feel good about it,
making them feel that he is running things
and because,
because you can absolutely lead from the shadows if your ego allows it.
Because a lot of times when we want,
when we lead,
we want everyone to know that would lead him.
I want everyone to know that I'm in charge.
I don't want them to know that.
Right.
That's really hard when you're leading from the shadows,
a lot of times,
not even the people that you're leading recognize overtly that you're leading.
Think about that.
So the people that are actually following you don't even know that they're
following you.
They don't.
They don't consciously know it.
Maybe if they were to break down and you give,
gave him like,
Hey,
who do you think has actually given you instruct vehicle?
Well,
I think that might be probably,
that seems like it's echo.
Okay.
But they don't like consciously think about it.
So that's what you need to do.
You need to suppress your overt leadership.
Not Step on the boss's toes.
Massages leader who would massage his ego a little bit.
Because if you do get your response,
do you want to help?
Right?
You want to be helpful.
You want to lead these people in a great way.
If you don't,
if you get your responsibilities taken away or you get fired,
then you can't help anyone,
anybody.
You're not gonna help the team at all.
So you have to be smart and you have to play the game to win his confidence and
his trust.
So he does let you lead.
And what's going to do that when he realizes that you're going to not going to
step on his toes,
that you're going to give him the credit because he wants a credit.
He's an EGOMANIAC,
right?
He's controlling.
So that's kind of what you need to do.
Now,
this is the weird thing and this came up at the muster.
People don't want to hear me say that.
If I come up against a boss,
the big ego,
what you need to do is back down.
People don't want to hear me say that.
They say they want to hear me.
Say if you come up against someone with a big ego,
what you do is you go up to them and you show them that they ain't got nothing
on you.
Yeah,
don't back down.
Don't back down to that guy with a big ego that's weak.
You'll it's,
and what I said at the monster and I said,
I said,
listen,
because I could see it.
Yeah,
I could see it.
People are like,
oh,
the youngest Jocko isn't always as hardcore as I thought he was because he's
going to back down to somebody with a big ego.
And I said,
guess what people,
this is why you feel that way.
If there was a a machine gun nest on a hill and there was a bad guy in there and
he's killing a bunch of people shooting that machine gun and everyone in the
room wants to look at Jocko and say,
Jack was brave and jock was tough,
and Jock,
who's going to charge that machine gun nest and take that guy out?
Well guess what?
A machine gun belt fed weapon in an elevated position.
Bunkered in.
I'm not going to take that guy out.
I can't,
it's a heavily defended position.
I can't do that.
So what Jocko does his backs down.
I hide it.
I get behind cover so I don't die
once I've gotten behind cover so I don't die.
I look at echo and I say,
echo,
stay here.
Shoot some rounds at this guy.
Occasionally distract him.
I'm going to flank him.
So that goes going to keep under cover himself.
He's going to playing some rounds up with a machine gun nest.
While he's doing that,
I'm going to scurry away like a little baby,
like little sneaky little squirrel.
And I'm going to go round to the flank cause the machine gun isn't a bunker,
right?
So we can't see out the sides.
Um,
and coming up the side,
I'm going to get right to the assignment to toss a grenade in there and kill
him.
I'm going to take out the ego,
but I didn't do it.
Go and head on.
Yeah.
So what happens is people come and go up against this big ego and they want to
be the hero and they want to be aggressive when they want to default aggressive
Jocko,
you say,
be you.
You got a chapter in your book,
default aggressive,
man.
I'm going to be default aggressive against that ego.
Wrong answer.
The right answer is indirect warfare.
The right answers,
maneuver warfare,
the right answers.
You flank these people,
and by the way,
if I do charge that machine gun nest or I do attack that guy's ego,
guess what?
I die or I get fired and now I'm no good to anybody.
So it's people have this desire to be the strong hero and you have to fight
that.
That's your ego.
That's my ego charging the machine gun nest.
I'm going to go do this on the man.
No,
I'm actually not the man.
It's a machine gun.
No position.
I'm going to die.
You have to be smart.
Yeah,
like Glenn,
go attack that you go head on.
Don't attack heavily defended positions head on.
Period.
Like you sit in training day,
your voice,
a movie training day.
No,
come on Ray,
you've watched it anyway.
He says,
the Shit is chess,
not checkers.
He's not the first person that ever said,
but it was dealt when he said it.
In my opinion.
Nonetheless,
yes.
Default aggressive isn't default aggressive
it to head.
It's default.
Default aggressive in being effective.
Yes.
Really.
You're effective or ineffective.
The end of the day muster up being,
you know,
I listen.
Lafe knows what he's talking about it like that.
Yeah,
man,
it's good.
Jocko
question.
Yes.
Okay.
How do you shift your mindset from individual contributor to manager growing a
company from nothing to something required being an individual contributor in
getting a lot done with a little,
but as we grow,
it's clear that I need to hire people for specific roles and except the,
except that I can't do everything.
I'm very used to getting stuff done and doing everything myself and it feels a
little weird trusting someone else to do it.
How can I shift my mindset to appreciate being a manager over an individual
contributor?
So,
uh,
straight up out of the gate,
you are actually failing as a leader by doing what you're doing,
but by Dubai,
by continuing to do things yourself,
get in the weeds and not let people lead.
You're actually failing as a leader and therefore failing the team.
So number one,
you have to watch out for that.
And you know,
by the way,
that means the more time that you spend in the weeds getting stuffed on yourself
because you're so perfect.
That's the last time that you're thinking about strategy.
That's the last time that you're thinking about,
you know,
what's going to happen tomorrow in future operations.
And that's not good to be in that situation.
So,
uh,
first of all,
you need to build the trust with these people.
You don't have to give 100% trust to someone out of the gate.
If,
if I,
if we were in a company and I hire you and I'm going to have you doing some
task,
that doesn't mean I say,
Hey,
echo,
here's the task.
Go do it.
And now I'm just going to walk away.
I don't even know you.
I don't know how well you can do the task,
so I'm going to say,
Hey,
echo,
here's the task.
Actually watch me do it.
Okay,
you've seen me do it now I'm going to watch you do it.
cool.
You seem to be doing that pretty well.
I'm going to come check on you in two hours.
See how it's going?
Come back two hours.
Next day I check you once every five hours.
Next day I check you in the morning.
I check he wants in the afternoon.
Next day I just check you at lunchtime.
Maybe two,
three,
four days later.
I check you once every other day.
Pretty soon you're good to go.
And guess what I'm doing?
I'm doing something else.
Doing something that I should be doing.
I built the trust.
I confirm that you know how to do it.
I you trust me because now I trust you were building some team and some
relationship,
so that's all good.
So to the original point though,
I think the way that you shift your mindset is to recognize that micromanagement
is actually failure.
No progress is made while you're micromanaging.
The longer you are micromanaging someone,
the longer it takes for them to develop as a human being and as a useful person
in your organization.
Every minute that you micromanage someone is a minute of them.
Not Thinking for themselves is a minute for them not taking ownership of
something.
Because if I'm micromanaging your task,
you're not taking ownership of it.
If you're not taking ownership of it,
we know where that leads.
So
let people learn.
Let people lead and to not do that is failing.
Don't fail.
One time one Otl in Hawaii,
you get your driver's license at 15 Dang,
I dunno know what it is now.
That was long time ago,
but I learned to drive with my dad before that.
You know,
when we're young,
we get quite as dirt roads everywhere,
so he's like,
hey,
you know,
and it started with when we were young,
when were young,
young,
like seven,
eight years old.
We'd sit on his lap,
so he'd do the shifting in the gas and the brake and stuff like that.
Dirt roads,
we just do the steering.
That's what it kind of started with.
Then after a while he's like,
okay,
now we're just going to learn how to do this.
You know,
it was a manual stick shift.
So he was like,
okay,
now you just learn how to go right in.
Now it's go and shift gears and all on the dirt road,
whatever.
And so what else?
Like fifth just turned 15 or maybe even 14 and he was like,
Hey,
um,
he's like,
all right,
let's go drive.
You know?
Usually it'd be like we were going to the beach,
so on the way home,
hey,
let's take this dirt road.
You can steer kind of thing.
But this was actually like,
okay,
let's go drive.
So I'm like,
all right,
bye.
He popped,
he plops me in the front seat and he goes,
all right,
take us there.
And we were going wherever we were going down to the beach.
It's like,
all right,
take us there.
I was like,
Dang,
I don't know.
I've steered before.
I've shifted.
I haven't done the whole thing all at once,
but he was sitting right there.
He just said,
take us there.
I was like,
dope.
I took,
took them there,
whatever.
He didn't critique much,
you know.
Um,
but I got there and he just kind of let it happen.
It was the same kind of thing where first he's checking my steering,
they knees check.
This is over time then the years and yeah,
after awhile it's like buoys doesn't I he's still managing these right there.
If you could slide his foot over to the break if you need to do,
I guess if need to put his hand on the wheel,
steer you away from the oncoming truck if need be.
And at the same time he's letting me make little micro mistakes.
I hit the curb a little bit and it was more like,
you know,
stick shift,
do too much or yeah.
Well and he let that happen.
He cause that's my thing to figure out the field cause each car is different and
it's cool because that's actually good.
All at one time we were going on an operation on my first deployment to Iraq and
we were driving a far distance is through cities we'd never been through before.
And we've got turned around in the city and we work had a far way to go to our
objective.
It was a kind of a high profile operation and work.
We stop and I hear the call on the radio like all stop and I say something
along the lines of,
you know,
what's up?
And you know the,
the,
the point man,
which is the lead Nav in the vehicles,
he comes up on the radio EXEC.
I'm trying to get my bearings,
a little stress voice,
how walk up.
So I get out of my vehicle just to make sure this guy's one of my bros and I
walk up to the vehicle and he's in there and I could see he's,
he's flustered,
he's flustered and he's uh,
you know,
um,
I don't want to say embarrassed,
but he's flustered and now I'm there,
you know what I mean?
Yes.
And I think his thoughts are Jockos,
you know,
Jack was going to be mad or whatever.
Yeah.
And I go up and he's,
he's cracks open the door,
right.
I opened the door on the Humvee and I go,
you know,
what's up,
man?
Does in the most mellow voice.
I thought I'd go,
Hey,
what's up man?
He goes,
I don't know where we are.
And I was like,
cool man.
Well we'll set security,
let me know when you've got it dialed.
And he's like,
all right,
cool.
And that's what we did.
And you took like,
you could see his face,
like he just turned back to computer,
started working.
But when I walked up to me and he could see that he was panicking because you
know,
you got read a bunch of vehicles,
you know you've got seven vehicles with us and they're all driving around and
now you've done two laps around.
The news is not fun and there's,
and you know,
you make it through like pass the enemy.
One time you got away with,
now you went by him three times
and everyone in the whole troop is sitting there in the vehicle.
It's going,
hold on Jack Ass is gonna run us by this checkpoint again or I just think again.
Yeah,
all of us.
So,
but yeah,
I just went up,
hey bro,
what's going on that I'm just trying to find.
I don't know where we're at.
Okay.
We're going to set security.
Let me know when you've got to figure it out.
It'll be good.
It's so good,
man.
And that's bad.
That's so good on you because you know everyone that feeling the stress of like
what you're seeing for sure.
He was like,
Dang,
where's this guy leaning?
That's what the hell does he not know?
I'm sure everyone was feeling that.
Yeah.
Then it's like,
all right,
I got to kind of detached from that feeling and goes,
Dang.
And then,
you know,
I got on the radio because that was,
I just said,
uh,
I said the guy's name.
I was like,
Hey,
he's just getting it sorted out right now.
We're gonna be rolling here at about a few minutes when we,
when we know where we're at and everyone's,
you know,
set security,
boom,
done.
There was another time we got ambushed on that same deployment.
Sure.
And I was in vehicle number two and we were in a big convoy and the ambush
pretty much was aimed at the center and then the back of the convoy.
So a bunch of machine gun fire,
a bunch of RPGs and nothing really hit.
And in fact,
nothing did hit.
The RPGs went over us.
And,
and I was,
I would never say much on the radio,
right?
Sure.
And the guy in the back vehicle,
uh,
these actually the platoon chief,
but I say I didn't say much,
but clearly we just got ambushed.
I mean,
there was a massive fire and explosions going off and we power,
you know,
we go through that,
we continue on and the platoon chief in the back,
he says something on the radio,
something along the lines of,
he's like,
you know,
comes up on the road.
He's like,
Hey Jack,
who,
you know,
we just got hit with an ambush back here.
And I got on the radio and I was like,
Roger.
And,
and you know,
it's like,
it's it,
you know,
whatever it goes.
Okay.
I guess we're all right.
You know,
it's like all good.
All good in the hood.
He did me like that one day.
Yes.
In fact,
when I say I think,
I mean,
I remember the time you didn't mean gay,
so I was,
forgive me right now.
You just talked about an actual ambush or actually happened.
I'm talking about something the way less impactful.
Just barely.
At least you're asking for forgiveness before you tell a grocery store.
It was actually this pocket we had recorded like a week or something early.
So it's was like boom,
let me finish the whole thing,
get it ready to get pushed out.
All I need.
It was done.
All I had to do is press the button to make it live.
That's all I had to do.
And this was like a week.
I think it might have even been two weeks in advance.
Wow.
Those were the good old days.
Yeah.
But um,
and then the day came,
it was so done and out of my mind.
The day came and I was just like,
Hey,
I don't know.
This is not on my mind.
So long story short,
I,
I didn't do it,
so
I didn't press publish.
She was ready to go anyway.
So I wake up in the morning as he messaged a bunch of Twitter posts.
Right.
I understand that.
But I got a text message,
I think there might even been a phone call.
Oh No,
no,
no.
It was a phone call and a text message from you this,
you know,
this is,
this is something,
you know,
I'm like,
all right.
No,
I had no idea it was out of my mind.
I was like,
oh,
something that obviously is something,
you know,
I get this early in the morning by the way.
So I look at it.
Um,
and also I listen to the voice message first.
It was,
you all call me like,
hey,
how's it going?
Good morning.
So it was,
he goes,
um,
just to sort of let you know,
it's Wednesday,
you know,
we have that put that podcast we recorded.
That's,
you know,
that's supposed to be going on right now.
So whenever you can,
whenever you're ready,
go ahead and post that.
But it wasn't like all the Twitter post,
where's,
where's the book?
Which book is a slacker,
you know all that.
Okay,
whenever you're ready,
it's all good.
You know?
I didn't know what happened.
Maybe you're under more stress.
You never know.
You got to think when you're in a leadership position,
not that I'm like the leader here,
but if you're in a leadership position,
you don't know what someone else is going through.
Maybe you had some technical issue and I'm like going to call you up and be
like,
well,
where's that thing?
And now you freak out.
You're making it worse.
Yeah.
I don't need to make it any worse.
There's something going on like you were sleeping or whatever.
I didn't want,
you know,
but you always think about the respective of the other person that you're
dealing with and you don't want to escalate things that's not going to help.
Just deescalate.
Hey man,
just
wondering what's up with new,
if you need anything from me on the podcast,
maybe we need to rerecord it.
I don't know.
Let me know.
I'll be over.
That's what we're here for.
Like with two people shouting at each other and you chime in so he's still off
drowning and you're three people shouting.
Yeah,
messing it up.
Anyway.
Next question
Jocko.
I'm not sure I agree with your statements not to pursue belts in Jiu Jitsu.
It doesn't seem wrong to me to benchmark success using a rise in rank as a
quantifiable measure of success as a person is working to master their craft.
Any craft.
It's nice to have markers for accomplishment and engagement.
Wive belts.
Why have belts if they're not to be strived for or why have them.
Right.
And that's actually a little conversation I had that I,
as soon as he asked me this,
this is with Brandon,
you know,
Brandon picked birth yet.
Uh,
he's,
he's been around like since day one in the game here.
And we were going back and forth on some and he said,
he actually sent me this random cause he sent me texts about stuff,
you know,
whatever,
we're doing some projects and,
and whatnot.
And he sent me this random thing.
Well,
I guess it's random to meet.
It was random to him.
Maybe he just listened to a podcast where we were talking about this,
but he said,
you know,
hey,
I don't know,
you don't want to know what I agree with this stuff about belts.
Yeah.
And so,
and by the way Brandon is had a goal of doing a hundred burpees and 10 minutes.
Brandon is in good shape.
He's an athlete,
athletic dude.
And for some reason he can't do a hundred burpees and 10 minutes.
I don't know where he's at right now.
We are publicly calling him out to post his,
you know,
video video,
no cuts,
no cuts or maybe it doesn't have to post the whole thing.
I take his word for it cause he's owned it a bunch of times.
You'll put like he'll do a hundred in.
Oh no I think of what he's been doing.
He's been doing 10 minutes worth however many he can do.
He gets like 84 yeah food and he'll post it like I did 84 in 10 minutes you can
do 10 that the 10 tens of one to 10 every within 30 10 every minute or
something.
It has to be less cause actual burpees.
We'll take a certain amount of time.
Yeah,
that's what I'm telling you.
10 in a minute is not that hard.
Yeah.
But plus your rest 10 burpee pull ups in a minute is harder but still a good
measure.
So just regular burpees
but back to the conversation.
I'm going to try that by the way.
Okay.
So Brandon hit me up and,
and you know I understand belts,
you know and it's cause cause we've sent on here like don't worry about bells,
don't worry about the bells.
The bells are going to come.
I understand belts and I understand trying to earn a rank and that's cool.
But I'm telling you at some point,
and I think this will happen to everybody
at at some point Jujitsu becomes a lot more than just belts.
And eventually the Jujitsu itself
completely bypasses what the belts are and what the belts mean.
Now I could,
you could say back to me like,
well that's because you're a backhoe.
And so that's why you feel that way because of course they don't matter to you.
You're already a black box.
You,
you know,
but the fact is that that didn't happen to me.
A black belt that happened to me at like purple belt.
I think about midway of my purple belt time.
I had no care whatsoever of what bell color I was.
This is literally zero and I just wanted to get better.
I just wanted to know more.
I just wanted to keep training and it never even thought about it after that.
And like,
even like degrees on your PR,
on your black belt,
the Pete,
I was talking to Pete Roberts the other day and he's like,
well what degree are you,
you know,
he's a black belt and blah blah blah.
He's like,
what degree are you?
And I was like,
man,
I don't know.
I got my black belt in 2005 what does that mean?
You know what I mean?
Like I don't have the tape on there with how many degrees I am.
Not that I don't respect it,
but I just don't care for me personally.
So,
and I think that this isn't like,
he's like Brandon talk about,
you know,
to master any craft.
I think it's the same with any craft that you're trying to master.
Yeah.
If you're trying to master the craft,
yeah.
Hopefully.
And eventually the craft itself becomes more important than the rank that comes
with being skilled at the craft.
Yeah.
That's what I would hope for.
That's what,
by the way,
that also makes it a lot easier to keep pursuing because I don't care.
My,
I'm not sitting there going,
Oh God,
I hope we get a stripe on my belt today.
No,
I don't care if I get to start my belt,
I want to go learn more.
And guess what's going to propel you towards more stripes?
Wanting to learn more,
wanting more stripes does not propel you towards getting more stripes.
What propels you towards getting more stripes and getting advanced in any craft
is getting better at that craft.
So focus on getting better at the craft.
Yes sir.
The belts are going to come.
Even your belt is going to come one day.
Preach it.
I'm not concerned with belts,
so we're glad you're not,
that you're going to go up much in your future
nonetheless.
Yet.
And I think that this,
it's like a matter of perspective.
The Kit,
first off,
you've been a black belt and thinking that or whatever and be like,
yeah,
that's easy.
It seems like that's obvious that,
oh,
it's easy for you to say because you're a black belt,
but at the same time it doesn't kind of go along with that detachment thing.
It's like,
Hey,
I'm not in the game.
There's no reason for me to be striving for any belt right now so I can be
detached.
I'm not emotionally invested in the whole situation.
I can look back in and at the same time understand when I came up,
me being focused on belts would not have gotten me here.
You know,
like you have that clear vision.
I that's natural.
It's a natural thing to be like a blue belt and Oh,
I wish I could wear that purple belt and everyone would know me and respect me
as a purple belt and Abi calm.
It's tapping some of the purple belts right now.
Yeah.
In Bro d there's a side note,
I don't know if you know this,
but if you know the feeling of wanting that purple belt really bad and I just
want that purple belt and your skills from your,
from your instructor standpoint don't match purple belt and promotion time comes
along and you're okay,
this is a damn.
I get my bread and you don't get that purple belt bring.
You know how sad you're going to be real.
So I had,
I have known people that quit the gym straight up cause they didn't get promoted
on a,
on a certain day.
And you know what that is?
That's really sad.
It is.
It's said from top to bottom for sure.
That's a side note.
But I guess sad wasn't even the right word.
Well it's sad for them.
Yes.
Because if you were here in that zone where you should be getting your purple
belt,
that sometime maybe this promotion,
maybe next promotion,
maybe some other promotion,
that means your dedicated Jujitsu and now you're just going to walk away because
you didn't get belch.
Yeah,
that's,
yeah,
it's rough.
And like I said,
like that state of mind can really,
really gem.
UIC.
Yeah man.
True Story.
And I've heard of people where they didn't get their belt and then maybe someone
else did not,
maybe straight up other people did and it was their belt,
you know,
like Super Mad to the point where they're vocal about it.
I tapped that guy out.
Why did he get his belt public openly saying that.
So yeah,
it,
it'll jam you up.
Just that whole mindset.
One thing I would say to those people that might be thinking that way for my
perspective and for many Jujitsu instructors,
the you're,
you're advancing and you're getting promoted based on your potential,
not based on your skill level to like people because you might be,
you might not have a lot of potential.
And so,
you know what,
hey man,
the guys,
you know,
he can't train.
He's 68 years old and he's been training for a year and a half.
He's learned a lot of knowledge.
He's here all the time.
I mean,
he can't tap out any other blue belts.
We're giving him his blue belt because for a potential of him as a 68 year old
man that never worked out before.
And now he's training Jujitsu.
Do that guys a blue belt.
Yeah.
Um,
now the further you go up,
you know,
black belt is a little bit more serious.
Uh,
so it was brown,
so it was purple.
But I'm saying you're getting judged against yourself.
And that's an extreme example by someone else.
By the way,
not by yourself.
You're being judged by your instructor,
not yourself.
Yeah,
that's right.
That's right.
It's just like,
yeah,
man.
And that's the,
and that's an important thing.
What's your,
to your point,
everything that we're talking about right now makes Jujitsu suck.
Right?
It makes sure to sees it.
Like it makes it a,
maybe it'll make you mad,
it'll make you frustrated,
it'll make you,
it'll make it political.
And this guy got an,
I didn't know.
That's not for me.
I just don't like it.
That stuff.
Yeah.
You know,
don't even like that stuff.
So,
uh,
when you're ready,
your instructor's going to promote you until then.
Keep training.
Yeah.
And by the way,
also in your work skills,
when you're ready to get promoted,
you'll get promoted.
Yeah.
And if you're not ready,
you won't.
Or there's not an opening,
you won't,
you know what you do to solve that.
Don't get frustrated,
don't get all crazy.
Don't blame the guy that did get promoted.
Don't undermine him.
You know what you do?
Keep kicking ass.
Wait.
Next time it'll be your turn and enjoy what you're doing.
Master your craft.
Yes sir.
Don't let your craft become your master.
I just said that thing.
I liked it.
And that's what happens,
right?
Yeah.
The thing control you instead of you controlling the thing,
instead of you mastering it,
it's starting to master you and getting your head back.
Yeah.
But he doesn't make a good point.
And here's the thing is that this is a mix of perspective.
So where,
um,
or a clashing of perspectives where he was like,
aren't,
you know,
as a person working to master their craft,
any craft,
it's nice to have markers for accomplishment and engagement.
That's true.
And you know what?
I actually texted back to him.
I'm like,
hey man,
I know I'm not normal.
I'm not normal.
And all I need is a rock and a hill.
That's when I texted to him and he laughed.
Right.
But so,
so there are normal people that need to have,
like I want a goal,
I want to see,
I wanted to have a checkpoint and that's okay.
Yeah.
And that's why,
guess what,
there are belts in Jujitsu and you can get,
sir,
I don't,
we don't really give a lot of stripes out at victory like me,
Jeff Glover,
rain lister,
Craig,
James.
I mean we will give out like occasional stripes,
you know,
for various reasons.
But most of the time it's like,
oh,
the guys ready for his next belt.
Just give it to them.
Yeah.
And you shall live stripes.
That's a subtle thing in my opinion.
Like I've stripes don't reflect much compared to bullet belts nonetheless.
Yeah.
Cool.
Blue Belt,
right.
That guy was the deal.
But he's saying,
and you know what to to degrade what you're saying and what Brandon is saying,
you know,
when we do a lot of stripes and a lot of different colored belts kids,
right.
And that's needs going to be the point yet as a grown ass adult Brandon
now as a grown man,
you should be like,
I'm just here to learn.
Yeah.
Well to me what he's saying doesn't clash with what you're saying in my opinion,
no matter thing with Brandon is Brandon is,
you know,
I don't know him that well,
but you know,
we go back and forth a lot.
He's a guy that's like metric-driven,
you know,
like I'm going to get somebody to get this and would get that and that's
awesome.
That's what makes him successful in what he does and the craft that he has
mastered.
Very successful.
But he likes to have those.
Yeah.
Those measurements have metrics to go off and say,
look,
I just crushed this,
this goal.
Boom.
Done.
Yeah.
So,
well,
yeah.
And so with belts is going to be a little bit different.
Just like with promotions that you know,
based on a skill.
So you,
he says it's nice to have markers in your thing.
It is nice of course after when you got your black belt for you to say,
I don't care the fact that I got this black belt,
I don't care about that at all.
I don't know if I would believe no,
no,
you're,
you'd be correct.
Yeah,
I was.
I was stoked.
It's just a matter of what you're striving for.
What kind of surprise me do like I wasn't expecting it.
Right.
Which should tell you something.
Yes.
I wasn't in there like tonight's probably going to be big night.
No,
I like showed up at the gym and trained or whatever and then all of a sudden it
was special ceremony time and we've got the black belts.
Yeah.
And I was stoked for sure.
I was stoked to putting,
you know what's funny is like at the team,
like people,
people like,
I don't know who heard about it,
but people are like,
hey man,
I heard you got your black belt.
And I was like,
yeah,
yeah.
But I didn't tell anyone.
I wasn't like,
hey everyone,
I got my black belt.
Yeah.
You know?
But you know,
you know what?
You know what belt I cared the most about was my purple belt.
Yeah.
When I got my purple belt I was super pumped.
At that time it was a big deal.
Getting your purple belt.
I got my purple belt from Fabio Santos.
Yeah.
I wasn't given away then.
Purple belts either know
you had that,
that thing.
Yeah.
And you know what with and I don't know,
cause obviously I wasn't there at that time,
but I think it's always going to be like that.
Well,
if you get a purple belt,
that's a big deal.
Even now it seems like is definitely a big deal because there's just so many
people now doing what you did to no purple belt.
Purple belt is a legitimate,
when you're a purple belt,
you will not lose in a fight to a normal person.
No.
In my opinion.
Oh,
could you get caught with a punchy Asher,
but a normal,
you know,
you've got a very high,
high percentage of winning a fight against a normal person.
If you are a purple belt in Jujitsu,
a good purple belt.
Yeah.
Meaning not someone that just like got a purple belt for no reason.
Right,
right.
Real real perpetrator Jujitsu.
I mean,
a purple belt.
You're rolling.
When I roll with a purple belt,
it's a good role.
You know,
it was a good role.
It's not like,
oh,
this guy's just a purple belt,
blue belt.
Most blue belts,
you don't have to worry about much of anything.
Yeah.
When you're at a higher level.
Yes,
yes.
Yeah.
I mean,
you're not worrying where you're rolling with most blue belts.
Right.
I'm worried when I wrote with everybody.
No,
no,
no.
Worried.
Why?
No,
I'm just joking.
Yeah,
I dig it.
He's not saying you're disrespectful,
but I'm not saying you're disrespectful to a blue belt,
but,
but realistically,
you know that chances are there's no possible way for them to submit you very
small for both skill levels.
Don't match.
Slap a triangle on you or something and grab your arms somewhere.
Well,
yeah,
uh,
that can help.
Noah,
you rolled with Noah lately.
He tapped me out.
Oh Damn.
I mean not,
but yeah,
like within the last year,
he straighten my arm out real far.
Yeah.
I had to go into level nine,
defense mode agency escalate.
Oh,
I would be full.
And I,
and he me,
that was
the thing,
you know,
we're rolling and,
and all of a sudden,
and he's a purple belt.
That's,
there you have it.
There's a classic example in this.
I'm going to give him,
I'm going to give him a nickname right now.
Good.
Noah,
because he's good and he's very handsome by the way.
He's better than your team.
I'll let you judge that one.
But he's better than a typical purple belt though.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
But nonetheless,
to your point,
that's exactly to your point though.
If you have a purple belt,
you're,
you're nuts.
You're not,
you don't have many holes.
No.
Maybe some timing things,
maybe some,
you know,
whatever.
Yeah.
He's a classic example.
No,
it was a good purple belt watch out.
But yeah,
you don't pursue will ask me all the time.
When do I get my brown belt?
No,
I'm just kidding.
he doesn't care.
He's the type of dude that is like,
Hey,
I'll just get to sit around,
tap everyone out.
Maybe one day they'll give me a belt.
Maybe they won't.
I don't care.
Keep crushing it.
And that's how,
and tapping out Echo Charles.
No Bro.
What's up?
Did you give him your brown belt once you got tapped out by him?
I want it to do you know what's cool when you get tapped out by a lower belt?
It's a guess what Jujitsu works.
They should be able to wear your belt for this for the rest of your life.
No,
it works.
You do a Jujitsu move against me.
I'm going to tap out to it.
Yeah.
Like that's the way it works.
And you know,
you know,
I might try the defense,
but the Jujitsu works.
Yes sir.
I mean we just saw Roger Gracie Hodra Gracie against boot Chach yeah.
And people were a little bit freaked out and I was like,
yeah,
Jiu Jitsu works.
Yeah.
You know you get that choke on boot JETRO boutiques.
Is it animal?
Yeah.
Savage,
yes.
But get that Geek Color Sunken choke and you got,
you got Hodrick Gracie x amount of times world champion.
Can you imagine his grip strength or you rolled with them?
Grip strength.
It was really good.
But,
and I'm not to go into a whole thing about Hodges game,
but he has this thing where,
this is weird if you don't know the depths of Jujitsu,
but he has this feeling that he has all bases covered.
So he's not necessarily,
his game isn't to out hustle you as not to out speed you.
And it's not that strength you for sure,
but it's like he,
it's like he has this whole base,
like all his bases in the Jujitsu situation,
they're all covered.
So he'll do this thing that,
and he was trying to do them.
We checked,
but you know,
it was just really,
really good.
He'll grab one sleeve with the opposite hand,
grab the elbow from closed guard way.
I know Paul and he'll just wind up on your back and there's nothing you can do
about it while you're a little defensive.
He's got those covered,
no problem.
And it's just this thing that,
it just,
it's,
it's like this eventuality that you have no defense for it.
That's how it feels his whole game.
So yes.
I mean it's crazy that he was able to bring that same game to someone like we
Cheshire.
Yup.
He was leaving just as a beast.
Yeah.
He's,
yeah.
It's just crazy.
But yeah,
that's how nonetheless,
back to the point,
don't pursue the belt.
That's not the pursuit.
The pursuit is getting better.
The belts will come when the bill comes to the,
to to Brandon's 0.1,
the belt comes.
That is nice.
And to me,
when you get your belt from your instructor,
not from yourself,
when you get old,
if you're personal.
But if you're the guy who's getting mad,
yeah.
If you're the guy that's getting mad and because you think you should've got
your belt,
you're thinking you're getting your belt from yourself.
That's what you're thinking in your head.
Yes,
yes.
Exactly right,
so forget that.
I'm ready.
Yeah,
Exactly.
It's not up to you.
You can tap out all the black belts.
It's still not up to you.
It's up to you instructor anyway,
when you get your purple belt.
Brown belt.
Black belt.
Yeah,
that's belt.
I would say this happens more times than not.
If you're a blue belt,
you're rolling.
You're getting good.
You're learning a lot when you get a purple but purple belt that's going to
empower you so much to be like,
now my standard just mentally is higher now.
I'm a purple belt now.
That's my minimum standard right now.
Well,
a purple belt is full on in the game.
Yeah.
Yeah,
for sure.
You can't really be super casual and get a purple belt.
I'm saying.
Yeah,
I'm saying it is empowering and it is you.
You're going to have a lot of pride with that?
Well,
I wouldn't say empowering.
I would say it puts you,
um,
it,
it raises the bar on you.
Yeah.
Like once you're wearing a purple ball,
you can't be,
you know,
now you're like,
I can't tap to these blue belts anymore.
You might,
but I'm saying same thing to me.
Tomato,
tomato raises the bar.
Yeah.
What did you say?
It raises your standards.
Yeah,
a rolling like my own basically.
Exactly what you said was raised.
Yeah.
I got to represent all this stuff.
It's like,
it comes with a sense of pride.
So yes,
it's a huge,
it's a deal.
And that's good.
I also,
when you're a blue belt,
enjoy being a blue belt,
you didn't take more risks.
You can get tapped out.
Doesn't matter.
You let it flow.
Let it flow 100%.
But yeah,
when you get that belt,
yeah.
Beat,
be happy,
be prideful,
posted on Facebook and thank your training partners,
all that stuff.
But don't just pursue the belt,
man.
It'll jam.
You don't pick Tim.
Next question.
I'm a 24 year old machinist.
I work CNC machines,
do setups in order tooling.
Most of the people I work with have worked here for over 15 years.
The owner of my company wants to make me the shop manager and honestly I'm not
too tore up about it.
I feel like the older guys who've been around won't want to take scheduling and
Mac manufacturing advice from a young guy.
I have good relationships with all the shop guys put.
I'm worried about stepping into this role so soon.
Only been with the company for three years.
Any advice?
Okay,
your boss isn't asking you to do this job if you're not ready for it.
That's,
that's number one and the fact that you don't think you're ready is a good sign.
I've said this before because it means that you're humble,
so you feel like that.
That's good.
That's probably one of the reasons why you're doing well and probably one of the
reasons that your boss thinks you're ready for the jobs because you're humble,
so that's good,
but you also have to remember that being humble has to be balanced.
Dichotomy
of leadership with confidence and even with a little bit of aggression.
So there's a reason that you're getting asked to do this job and the boss needs
you to step up.
Now just because you become the manager or the boss doesn't mean yet.
You have to start bossing people around,
right?
It actually means that you should remain humble,
that you should take input from them,
that you can still take advice from them as opposed to just giving them advice.
All those things are fine.
And I just kind of asked this question the other day,
young,
uh,
construction business and a kid and we were in a big meeting with a,
with a bunch of leadership from foreman to engineers all in the same room.
A bunch of great guys from a great company and one of the young engineers raised
his hand and said,
you know,
I'm young and I am going to be in charge of these guys.
You know,
I'm not sure I'm comfortable with these guys.
Had been doing it for a lot longer.
What can I do to,
you know,
gain their respect.
And I said,
okay,
who in this room knows more than that engineer back there about construction and
all these salty constructs in foreman's raised their hands.
And I said,
who?
You know,
who's gonna think that this guy's got the best idea?
Raise your hands.
All the hands go down.
And I said,
so this is what you're dealing with buddy.
I said,
now let me ask another question.
The group group,
if this kid comes in and says,
I know how to do this better than you.
Listen to me and do it my way,
who's going to have respect for him?
Raise your hand.
No hands go up.
If this young kid comes in and says,
Hey,
I'm an engineer.
I've been educated,
but I haven't been doing this for a long,
can you give me some recommendations on how we do this so we can do the best job
possible?
Who's going to have respect for him?
Everyone raises their hand.
So there you have it.
You,
you don't have to know everything as a leader.
No one expects you to everything,
especially as a young leader.
That's okay.
And actually when you admit that you actually gain respect,
when you ask for people's input,
you actually gain respect.
People get the paranoid feeling that if they don't know something,
they're going to be seen as weak.
It's not true.
So
you can just step up to the position.
Still be humble,
still take advice.
Now this doesn't mean that you're a pushover,
right?
That doesn't mean that you just listen to what everyone says and you don't make
any decisions.
No.
It actually means that you show respect to their experience and when it comes
time to make a decision,
you get the best input and then you make a decision and you explain your
decision.
And if your decision is wrong,
you admit it.
And if it's not wrong,
you push forward.
So that's what you need to do.
You're getting asked to be put in this position for a reason.
So do it get some things like a common one?
Yeah,
that one.
I'm 70 in the new role for sure.
Everyone asks that question.
I answered it again.
There you go.
For everyone's benefit,
including my own,
I learned from it every time.
That's the ethos,
right?
Colin?
Humble.
Yeah.
Be Open minded.
Take advice.
Yes,
yes,
yes.
Don't have to know everything.
Yes.
Three days ago
or neighbor young girl and one of my daughter's friends,
12 years old and she comes over there messing around.
They're swimming,
she grabs my daughter's jump rope and she's jumping rope and she does the cross,
you know,
you jump up and you cross crossover crossover.
Yeah.
So he does that.
And Man,
I used to jump rope back in the day,
but I never really could do the crossovers.
Let's face it nonetheless.
So she's jump roping in jumping rope and I'm like,
Hey,
do that cross the crossover thing again.
She does it.
She's doing,
you know,
she's 12 years old.
You've done.
I'm like,
Dang,
I never could do that.
And she's like,
well you just got to do it like this until that.
So I'm like,
okay.
I grabbed the rope and I try and the roasts do small,
so I go grab my rope.
Yeah,
I've got to jump rope.
Uhm,
well I told my daughter grab it.
So she grabs it.
And this is,
this is like a kind of like one of those pro speed ropes,
you know,
so it's like kind of,
so if I make a mistake on this rope is going to hurt.
I didn't have any shoes on.
I was barefoot.
So Hawaiian itself for sure 100% and then so I go forward,
I'm dumb or I can jump rope still pretty good right now.
It's still,
I haven't done it in awhile.
And she goes,
okay,
so right here at the top,
you know,
you,
you cross you,
this is where you want to cross at the top of try it.
Ooh,
he hits my foot painful.
And she's like,
no,
you got to do more at the time.
No,
no,
no.
Never showed the paint to the kids.
I try not to anyway.
So I was like,
okay,
boom,
fail.
She could,
she was like,
no more at the top.
You know,
it'll,
it'll just whatever.
So I'm like,
okay,
I do it.
And it took me four times,
how my fourth time I did it for the first time in my life.
By the way,
their crossover with the painful speed rope,
some,
some mental fortitude,
right?
They're throwing in so hardcore.
I did it.
You should've seen them,
but you should've seen the look on her end,
my daughter's face.
They were like,
oh.
Like it was,
you know,
like I just got my purple belt of something nonetheless.
So boom,
what do we have right there?
This situation,
this is what I took from it too.
We have a situation,
a full grown athletic,
arguably person learning to do something that's really not that easy.
Obviously,
if I've never done it in my life,
learning to do something that takes a fair amount of skill from a 12 year old
girl in real time.
And you know what I did
to boot gave her the credit.
I said,
Dang,
you are the the best teacher.
Yes,
exactly right.
So that's the thing,
the moral of your story,
which was a long story.
Yeah.
Be Humble.
You can learn from anybody and when you do learn from someone,
boom.
That's what I did.
See,
I said that in 13 seconds.
I know brow,
but I'm just saying it was impactful and it reminded me of that story.
Anyway,
next question.
Jocko.
Just checked out.
Podcast 21 with Tim Kennedy.
Awesome.
Raise the big time question though.
You and Tim agreed that cops who make controversial decisions slash mistakes do
so simply because they're not trained well enough.
That begs the question,
how much does the environment,
someone trains in impact their decision making?
How much tactical decision making is innate versus learned?
Could killing the ideology that,
that the insurgents buy into be better than killing insurgents or can they
simply not be reasoned with at any level?
There have been terrorist who flee their organizations and start new,
peaceful lives in other locations.
Okay.
Uh,
yes.
So the first part of the question,
yes,
you train how you fight and the more you train the morgue,
you reprogram your instincts.
So that's important.
You're reprogramming your instincts when you train and you get better instincts.
So that's what you do.
And,
and now when cops make mistakes,
oftentimes it's because of their lack of training.
Sometimes they make a mistake.
That is a mistake that got made.
You know it's,
it's a mistake.
That's all it is and they've been trained well and they still make a mistake.
I'm going to tell you the percentage of mistakes go down dramatically.
The more that you train in,
the more realistically trained and the more often you train,
you're going to get better.
No doubt about it.
But that's like an instinct.
You're training your instinct.
So that's so one thing,
this,
this idea that we could just attack an ideology of terrorists and then have some
of them convert.
That'd be a wonderful thing that you attack the ideology and then some of them
become peaceful,
productive members of society.
And if we did it like a full court press to try and make this happen,
we might be able to convert,
let's say we were really successful and be able to convert five or 10% a year.
Okay,
so that's great.
Then you have to remember that the enemy is also out there converting people,
right?
Probably at at least equal rate,
maybe even a little bit higher.
So we still end up losing the fight cause to break even is to loose cause
they're still out there doing what they're doing,
the Dow.
Um,
and in the meantime,
by the way,
there still
gaining territory or causing terror.
So it's not a good situation.
Now the examples that I use all the time obviously are Nazi Germany and imperial
Japan.
Both of those groups were like the current day jihadists they were looking to
take over the world.
And if we just tried to kill their ideas with our ideas,
we would be speaking German right now because we would not,
we couldn't have changed their ideas fast enough.
And by the way,
they were playing a different game.
If we were playing the game of let's chat,
exchange ideas,
the enemy is playing a different game.
So for instance,
if someone is trying to assault you and you're a pacifist and so you decide that
you're going to try and convince them of the virtues of nonviolence through,
through debate and the Socratic method and critical analysis and the use of
various rhetorical devices and that's what you're going to do.
And you might be the best debater in the entire world,
okay?
But none of those things are going to stop that assault her from punching you in
the face.
He's playing a different game and once you're on the ground,
he's going to start kicking you.
He's a violent person.
Now,
maybe if you were to be able to slow him down long enough to try and reason with
them,
he's not playing that game though.
He's there to attack you.
He's there to stab you so your ideas aren't going to defeat his ideas.
You don't have the opportunity to do that.
He's not playing debate.
So you have to know how to fight.
You have to understand a violence and you have to be prepared to use it.
And if you can,
if you can debate and you can win,
that's awesome.
Okay,
But if it doesn't work,
you need to be prepared to use violence as it's needed.
And it's the same thing on a larger scale.
Obviously we,
we can do everything we can to try and help snuff out this extremist ideology.
Let's prop up reformist as much as we can.
Let's try and bring economic opportunities to these improv rushed in and
deprived regions so that they're less likely to come under the psychological
grips of a death cult.
But at the same time that we're doing those procedures,
let's attack their strongest a factories of hate.
Let's go after their centers of gravity and let's snuff out and destroy those
individuals that clearly have no hope of reform and exist only to spread this
cancer of hate and violence and terror and death.
And if we attack on both those fronts,
hopefully one day where we can live in a world where we can solve problems,
not with physical force but with our intellectual power and that would be great.
Okay.
And unfortunately,
I don't think that day will ever come because there's always going to be someone
out there that's going to attack you regardless of your debating skills
and math.
Next question.
Yeah.
Long question here.
My general question is,
is there a point where it's no longer physically realistic to train Jujitsu?
Big Jujitsu today on the podcast?
Yeah,
Jujitsu heavy Jujitsu.
I'm okay.
Actually,
I noticed we were going back to Jujitsu a lot.
Yeah.
We took some questions that weren't about Jujitsu.
We turned them into Jiu Jitsu questions.
Sometimes.
Yeah,
I'm a former competitive athlete but have experienced various injuries that I
still work through on a daily basis.
I really want to get into Jujitsu,
but my only hesitation on my lingering injuries,
I don't know anyone who trains,
so I don't have any sense of how much is too much when it comes to physical
limitations and injuries.
I'm sure you must have had injuries over the years that hindered your training.
Were you able to modify your training to accommodate them them?
Although I have no experience,
I greatly respect the martial arts and the last thing that I would want to do is
waste the instructor or other students' time by not being able to fully
participate and or holding up the class.
I hope this question can benefit other podcasts listeners who may be wondering
the same thing.
However,
to give you the,
give you full detail in reference to the question,
I'm 26 and the injuries I'm dealing with are just the list left knee that I need
to work on daily to maintain full range of motion on my third ACL.
Meaning he had surgery three times.
Well yeah,
he's had three actually.
He said he had heard surgery seven times but that's his third ACL ACL surgery.
Oh yeah.
Sort of ligament been put in there.
Dang.
Yeah cause they replaced the ligament.
Yes.
It doesn't grow back and it doesn't heal.
So they got to give you a cadaver or they either give you your own from your hip
or your from your head or hamstring or Patella string and they put that in there
or they give you a cadaver one.
Yeah,
I had that.
I had ACL back in the cadaver my own from my hamstring.
Okay.
I've had said at seven surgeon,
well I haven't this back to the question.
I've had seven surgeries,
most recent being a fee moral oss,
the autonomy and cadaver meniscus transplant.
There you go.
I'm told one more major injury to the joint and I'm looking at a full knee
replacement.
Dang.
At 26 to less shoulder,
dislocated several times.
Torn ligament cartilage and label them.
Don't plan on having the surgery anytime soon.
And history and a history of multiple concussions.
I power lift,
jog,
metcon.
Hell yeah.
Regularly.
But all cutting sports.
But all cutting sports are pretty much out of the question.
Cutting all the sports.
Yeah.
Gotcha.
Nope,
he says,
but all cutting sports are pretty much meaning cutting yo when you know when you
caught on the field.
Oh,
cutting.
Gotcha.
Okay.
Cutting left.
Cutting.
Right.
I'm pretty sure that's what he means.
Oh,
okay.
Yeah.
I thought he meant you can jog.
He can do Matt Kahn's but he can't cut.
Gotcha.
Check.
Okay.
Either way,
I get,
I got you.
Um,
sports are pretty much on the question.
If Jujitsu isn't feasible,
do you recommend any other martial art that would better fit my situation?
Just getting tired of only tr trying to stay physically fit and would rather
incorporate a beneficial skill into my training.
Or is this all in my head and I should stop worrying and just get after it.
Thank you for any advice you can offer a podcast.
Thank you for your service.
Awesome.
Um,
so I kind of broke these out was,
let me,
let me break these out of here.
So his first general question,
is there a point where it's no longer physically realistic to train Jujitsu?
And the answer that really is yes.
But you can also train Jujitsu in a wide variety of levels of intensity of very
wide.
You could theoretically just go and learn the techniques.
You could just learn the techniques and never actually rolled to someone.
And if you couldn't do anything at all that would,
in my opinion,
I would still do that.
Yeah.
Just to,
just to know and understand it.
I would still do that.
Would you agree?
Yes.
And it now what you have to be watch out for is that you're going to want to try
them.
Yeah.
You're going to want to try it.
And it's so unreal and that's just,
that's what you're going to need,
want to do.
Now,
you know,
like I said,
you can do it from just from just learning the techniques,
only two all the way to competing in Jiu Jitsu.
And like I said,
you got to watch out that you,
if you can only learn them and maybe you can row light,
maybe you can find,
you can roll with light.
People are,
you can roll with really good brown belts that are light and that,
that use tell him,
you know,
up front,
hey,
I got injuries.
I'm not here to,
for an ego trip,
I just want to try the moves.
You better freaking keep your ego in check though,
which is what's so hard because you're going to think,
well this guy's kind of skinny dude,
get out of this.
And then you end up getting hurt.
So you can't let that happen.
So don't let your ego get in the way you might not want.
If you have all those series injuries like it sounds like you have,
you may not want to roll with anybody for a long time until you really truly
understand Jujitsu.
So that's question number one.
Yes,
you can learn it without much risk.
Actually,
you're very limited risk if you're just looking to learn the techniques,
you could learn it with very limited risk.
Um,
now the next question,
have I had injuries over the years and was I able to modify my training to
accommodate them?
Absolutely.
Yeah.
I've had ankle sprained ankles,
high sprains,
all that stuff.
And when that happens,
you see me training my bottom game a bunch because I'm not going to be on top.
I hurt my back one time really bad and I couldn't do an Oba.
This is what I was a blue belt,
couldn't do an Oompah,
couldn't do it.
Guess what?
I did elbow scraped.
My elbow scape got good because I could not do an Oba.
Uh,
I've had my MCL 80% tear,
get some guess what?
No factor.
Put It on and I,
I couldn't train for like a couple of weeks,
but then I put it on one of those hinged metal braces.
Strap that thing on tight.
Could I do closed guard?
No.
Could I do a triangle on someone?
Know,
did I have to be careful?
Yes.
Did I train?
Absolutely.
Uh,
my neck.
I had neck surgery and you know,
my neck now does it hurt?
Yeah,
go.
I end my whole game
is kind of based fundamentally around protecting my neck.
So I don't do certain moves that I used to do that work that are high risk neck
moves.
Interesting.
Right?
Like uh,
yeah,
there's just certain moves that I just don't do anymore because it's high risk
neck move and I don't want to put my neck into just into jeopardy.
So yes,
you do go through things now occasionally,
like I just got through,
uh,
a few weeks where I had three simultaneous injuries and it was a broken knuckle,
some kind of a knee issue and I had a gaping cut on my toe,
my big toe,
ripped half the skin off the monitor itself.
And so I said to myself,
okay,
I'll just tape up my entire body and still train.
No,
I didn't say that.
I said,
you know what,
this is,
you know,
my body telling me,
one injury you can get through two injuries.
Okay,
wait a second.
But when I finally tore my toe open,
I was like,
okay,
maybe it's time to take some time away from the mat.
So I didn't train for a few weeks.
Right.
Probably the longest.
I haven't trained in in it since.
I can't remember.
Uh,
but that's three injury stacked on top of one another.
And now I'm just thinking myself.
You gotta be kidding me.
Let them all heal.
And that's what I did.
Uh,
so that's that.
The next sort of question was,
if Jujitsu isn't feasible,
do you recommend any other martial art that would be better fit your situation?
I think you can always learn Jujitsu.
I think you could learn to box.
Um,
you could learn more.
[inaudible] you gotta be careful.
Be careful with more.
You got the knee surgeries you got,
I would say little to no sparring since you've had concussions.
Uh,
and like I said,
in all those cases,
you're going to learn to box and you're like,
well,
I don't think I want to try this out,
man.
Who looks pretty easy and that's powering ring.
I'm going to get in there.
Don't,
you've already have concussions.
You can't,
you got to keep your ego in check.
And then the last part of the question was,
or is this all in my head and I should just stop worrying and get after it.
Look,
we all have got to know our limitations.
You got to also know that sometimes you're putting limitations on yourself that
are too tight.
And you also got to realize that sometimes you can push yourself too hard and
overdo it and end up in a really rough spot where you've got a permanent injury.
Like,
you know,
right now my knee is not fully healed and so instead of doing nine rounds of
Jujitsu,
I did like four yesterday,
five yesterday,
five today,
you know,
not and,
and avoiding a couple of positions.
Right.
You know,
that's what I'm doing.
Yeah.
That's okay.
I can't go in there.
It happened the big and be like I'm
going to be on top right now.
No,
can't do it.
And the more impactful part is it can't have the big ego of like somebody comes
up with like,
hey,
let's roll.
Right?
Like,
okay,
I'll roll with you cause I don't want to look like a Wuss.
No,
no,
actually I got an injured knee can roll right now,
which I hate saying.
I guess by saying that,
I despise saying that I despise it,
but I know that I,
you know,
I got to heal up.
Yeah,
man.
So part of the game.
Yeah,
that's the ego in check.
But remembered Jerry Loudon.
Yeah.
So he had jammed up knees and I'd thought of him while I'm reading this case
question.
Yup.
Same Age maybe,
I don't know.
Do you ever do any,
might've been older.
Maybe like 32 or something.
Yeah.
So jammed up nice.
But you know,
he did some guy,
so he comes in and what he'd always do is he'd be like,
Hey,
let's,
he'd grabbed me because I've known him long time.
[inaudible]
he,
uh,
he'd be like,
Hey,
let's he what he called it youth.
He's like,
Hey,
do you want to play?
Meaning?
Like,
we're just,
we're just rolling.
You know,
just like how you said,
how you like,
how I warm up with Andy.
He's big and he's really good for that to history.
Now Dean is not good for that.
Yes,
it all roll.
Dean Dean will literally say to me,
Hey,
let's just get warmed up and then he'll get across side and smashed me for,
for for four minutes and 38 seconds and torture me.
So I do not do warm up rounds with Dean Dean.
Wait,
if you can go to hell no one around you here.
Obviously Dean does that on purpose.
Like because we're going to do that.
You wouldn't,
we do that.
Dean has two advantages.
Number one,
I'm not warm and that means there's no sweat yet.
So He's,
so there's,
there's like just friction and he can just secure positions and it sucks.
And,
and psychologically we both,
oh and the other,
the other advantage that he has is he's fresh because the deeper we go into deep
waters,
the better I'm doing because I'm in better condition than him.
I did get mad,
but he has those two advantages out of the gate.
He's going to make me pay.
So flooding.
You can tell him it's not like a little thing with a 20 something year thing
with dean.
Hey Man,
I dig it and that's probably going to continue to,
you know,
till you guys are both kind of,
we just had an incident yesterday,
man incident yesterday happened.
You know Ted talk about it.
No,
I already did.
Her words were exchanged loudly in the gym anyway.
Jerry is really good with that.
Where this is the guy and this guy situation more or less me wise anyway.
And um,
I think it was even both his knees.
Yeah it was,
you know,
so you can do that and you can get like a good movement.
Good Rolling.
Without that,
that impact,
you know when every once in a while you got to turn up the heat or whatever on a
guy.
Cause that comes from Eagle.
Yeah.
It's more of like this competitive kind of spirit of rolling Jujitsu.
That's kind of what it is.
So if you can avoid that,
you've got to actively avoided and still get that movement.
If you can find the right person and you can go and you can go,
you can learn,
you get more
or less live situations,
but you just can't be like,
you can't find that little fight in the fight.
You,
you gotta let that go.
Okay,
I get great.
But yeah,
you can learn for sure.
You can learn,
don't do take downs.
If you've got a nice situation,
don't do take down,
take down situation.
That's,
that's going to be hard.
All right.
Okay.
Last question.
And you know this,
this last question,
it's not really a question.
What would it look?
I get a lot of awesome emails and I get emails from people that have completely
turned
their lives around.
They've,
they've lost weight.
If they needed to lose weight or they've gained weight because they needed to
gain weight or they've gotten promoted or they've become a better parent or they
become a better spouse or they'd become a better kid.
Yeah.
And I get emails from people that have quit their addictions or they've,
or they've overcome their fear and I say what?
I get letters and packages and notes about all this kind of stuff,
then it's awesome.
I get,
I get people send me books for the podcast and pictures and drawings and,
and,
and military memorabilia or unit patches and coins from police departments and
fire departments and,
and military units is just,
it's awesome.
And,
and I,
um,
I'm so thankful for all that feedback
and it,
it drives me bad feedback that I get,
drives me to work hard and keep pushing to do this to the best of my ability and
try and get better at it.
But,
you know,
I,
I hear from people that have used the podcast and the discipline and the,
the,
the mindset of looking at things that are problematic as being good.
I hear from people that have used those things to overcome,
you know,
dark patches yeah.
In their lives,
you know,
whether it's depression or anxiety or even like full fledged despair.
And again,
when you hear from people that are turned that corner,
that's just incredibly rewarding.
Okay.
To know that there's,
you know,
there's people out there that are really changing for the better and turning
their lives from negative.
Okay to positive.
It's unbelievably rewarding.
But I also get
some other emails and I get some other messages
from people that haven't been able
to dig out of that hole to overcome that,
that despair.
I,
I hear from people sometimes that feel there's nowhere,
nowhere else to go.
There's no way out
and they don't have any more options
and they are considering
taking the only way out that they can see.
And that is they want to take their own life.
And
to anybody out there that's in that place,
you know,
I don't really know what exactly to tell you,
but I can kind of tell you what I think.
I think.
No,
I think,
no,
I think don't save that last bullet for yourself.
Don't save it for yourself.
You lock and load that last bullet and you shoot it at your enemy
and when you're out of bullets,
get out your knife and attack would that.
And if you lose your knife,
you grab your enemy by the fruit.
And You keep fighting
and you keep fighting and you keep fighting and you keep fighting no matter what
and you never quit.
Never,
never quit.
Okay.
And if you feel like your wife is in a place where you can't get any lower
and you don't think you can find any way out,
good
cause that means the ultimate challenge is ahead of you.
It means you can only go up.
Yeah.
And it also means that things are going to be tough.
Okay.
Things are going to be tougher than anything you can imagine.
But that storm that you're in from,
from your perspective,
it seems like that storm is enveloping the whole world.
But I'm telling you,
it is not
the storm that urine.
It is hard to see out of that storm.
It's a hard to see past it.
It seems like the storm,
it seems like a storm is everything
okay?
But the storm is not everything.
Andy old won't last forever.
You can get out of the storm and you will get out of the storm and when you get
out,
you're going to see this sauna.
Okay.
But right now you're being tried.
Yeah.
You're being forge.
You're being tested by fire and by pain.
Okay.
That's the test.
Don't fail the test.
Don't give in.
Don't quit.
Okay.
Don't ever quit.
Fight on
fight through the storm.
Fight through the pain and come out the other side.
Stronger and tougher and better.
A fighter.
A survivor.
Oh,
winter.
Okay.
Victorious
and
free from that storm.
Free from the darkness
free.
And I think that's
all I've got for tonight.
So
Echo Charles,
speaking of
being stronger and being better.
Yeah.
Maybe you could tell us some ways to
make ourselves a little stronger and a little better.
Yeah.
And at the same time,
sure.
Possibly support this podcast if they want to.
Yes.
You're under no obligation to support yourself.
Well,
I think as a human being you are,
but I'm just saying as far as the message here,
that's up to you.
But if you do want to,
what?
Pursue whatever you want to pursue,
your participation is required.
Does that make sense?
No.
Okay.
Anyway,
so I'm going to talk about on it.
So good fitness gear.
Good stuff.
I just got some fulvic minerals.
Hmm.
It's actually from that way.
Nonetheless.
They got some good stuff for any,
uh,
area of getting after it that you need to or that you want supplementation with.
So remember that jump rope story I told him right?
That wasn't on at jump rope.
Oh,
they're young.
Yeah.
Pro speed rope,
I think it's called.
It's like,
Bro,
there's a lot of technological advances in jump ropes back.
Yeah.
Back Elementary School for me.
He's just a piece of leather hide or what was mine like a row.
It was straight up a rope with a handle and another handle at the end.
That's it.
This one has like a swivel and has a thing.
It has a police system.
I Dunno.
Maybe.
I Dunno what it's called.
It's made out of this stuff.
It's like,
yeah,
it's good.
It's will's good.
Anyway.
Yeah,
that jumbo was good.
Um,
also kettlebells,
solid,
heavy,
heavy as you need varying weights.
Right.
I bought one for my daughter.
The,
what's the,
what is it?
The little monkeys Howler,
that's what it's called.
I think it's like 18 pounds or something like that.
She can lift it up.
She can't swing it.
She's for lifting it though,
right?
She's dead lifting it.
Good for me.
You'd be surprised,
man.
Little kids and my natural instinct for forming.
Exactly right.
Cause they're trying to find the perfect balance.
That's why they have no choice.
They do off that and we're just going to fall down.
My son,
11 months old now,
she started walking at straight up.
You'd kind of earlier than my other like nine almost 10 months.
That pour,
right?
Yeah.
He's to be outside.
That means he's
going to be an unbelievable athlete yourself repeating it.
Recruited right now.
That's what everybody thought.
That's what they say.
Everybody's kid is the best kid in the world.
Yeah.
That's what everybody thinks and by no means is that my message here,
but the message is you watch them do a squat to pick something out.
You're like,
Dang,
that's good for him.
So my daughter,
she's forced it picks up the the kettle bell little Holler and I'm like,
first I'm like,
oh shoot,
I don't know.
She should be picking it up.
She doesn't know what she's is.
She picks it up as this perfect form deadlift form lakes.
When my youngest daughter was like six or seven,
I had her dead lifting
pattern.
No,
no.
And I pushed her too hard and she was dead lifting and she liked our back.
Ah,
how old?
Like six or seven.
I mean she was just doing like double body weight
but it was with kettlebells and so you're not going that low so it makes it a
little bit easier.
So I thought she was dead lifting and my son was in there too and I think my
other daughter,
we were all just getting afterwards.
Sure,
sure.
And you know,
so I'm like,
can you can do this,
you can do this.
And we're escalating weights and going heavier and heavier and finally we get to
like a pretty big way.
I forget what it was.
It might've been,
might've been
maybe the 32 kilogram or something like that comes up.
So she lifts it and like right as she gets almost the top,
she gets the look on her face and like,
like moves sharp and then s and then she like started to tear up.
She dropped,
she didn't drop it,
she put it back down and she started to tear up and she's like,
I think something happened to me.
Baghdadi and I was like,
Oh God,
I'm the worst father ever.
Don't go with a heavy kettle bells for the kids or heavy dead lifting,
but they're not ready for it.
Yeah,
I'll go on record trade up and say,
don't buy kettle bells for your kids or program that you got sorted out for them
and when they're four or 11 months or whatever,
wait till they're six.
I don't do it.
I bought the Kettlebell because when I go out there,
that daughter dead lifting and like posted at one time people were all pumped
because it's pretty dope.
It's dope to see in a picture,
but man,
you can't get crazy with that.
I think if I'm lifting my kettle bells and they're cool,
they're the werewolf ones and you know all this stuff.
My daughter's out there,
she's cruising and she's watching.
She's like,
you know,
she obviously,
he let me try,
let me try it.
And she,
she wants,
she can't in the game.
I don't want her to pick up that where we'll fit.
We 62 pounds,
one of them.
You don't let her.
I don't,
I don't push her to put,
pick that up.
No.
She'll grab it and try out.
She doesn't pick it up.
No,
it's too heavy for her,
but she just wants to be like,
dad,
that's all it is.
So you got into the howler just has a little gift.
Do you know,
hey,
you got your own kettle bell.
You know how empowering that is.
I'm not saying that now.
Now let's lift Goodal bill's grow.
You're only for,
now you're on the pro.
It's not that.
It's for her to have her own little Kettlebell and beat,
you know,
it's like a cohesive thing,
you know?
No,
it's cool.
Just like she likes to do pull ups but not really snap out of pullet routine.
She reads where your kid,
I read it to her and she sees me doing pull up.
She's like my turn,
I want to do pullups now when she's able to get on her own program or be more in
a position to facilitate a program imposed upon her as the case may be not too
early.
By the way,
she'll be familiar with pullups.
She'll know the value of pullups plus dad does pull up,
so it's obviously cool,
you know,
and she's going to be down,
she's going to be kind of set for life in regards to pull ups,
kettle bells or whatever.
So I like salt back there.
Can you get those?
Oh,
the kettle balls on it.com with a jump rope or the jumper,
the jump ropes still nonetheless.
Don't,
I don't think actually,
I do think that those designer kettle bells,
those are kind of like the um,
that's the kind of the pre Madonna one actually.
No.
Yeah,
that's a wrong word though.
Now I'm okay with it.
They're dope.
They're just good.
Yeah.
You like them?
They're not like the hardcore dusty canon balls with handles your artistic,
not the ones I have.
Yeah.
The ones I have.
They're not like that.
I got all the,
the decent ones,
but they are cool.
If you walk into a gym,
you know,
you go to the gym,
you're wherever and there's a bunch of kettle bells,
right?
And you're,
you're looking for a certain weight and let's say there's the werewolf ones and
then there's the regular ones.
Which ones are,
you can hear me.
Is this a serious question or just like a basic question?
What do you think I would use werewolf ones probably.
Well,
nonetheless,
I think they're cool.
And Go ahead,
check them out.
[inaudible] dot com slash Jocko that's where you get it.
Support yourself really.
And a sports.
This podcast also,
if you are into these books,
we didn't read any books,
but I mentioned a few books today.
Mentioned Hackworth books.
Yeah.
Emission Dick winters books.
Where can you find those books?
Well,
ultimately you get them from Amazon,
like everything else.
Um,
but if you want to go through the list,
the specific books,
go to the website Jocko,
podcast.com section on the top or menu item on the top boom cause you to the
page with all the books by episode.
By the way,
actually I don't think I put extreme ownership on there,
but nonetheless click through there that's kind of jacked up.
Well actually exist over to the right,
so that's the thing.
Extreme ownership is covered it in the podcast,
so it's not going to be on the list of books covered either podcast because the
section is called books from the episodes unless maybe all of lay on and we'll
do extreme ownership.
Yeah,
that'd be cool.
That'd be like layers because you wrote the book,
you've experienced all the thing with life.
You do the audio book and now you're doing on the podcast,
so it's like a the thing.
Anyway,
go do that.
Go to Jocko,
podcast.com boom.
Choose whatever book or books that you want.
Click through there to get them.
Boom.
Got You.
That's a good way to support.
Yup.
Very good.
It's like I'm,
and it's what takes one,
one second,
two seconds and big support,
small action.
Big reactions.
Just saying [inaudible] can we start what you're saying?
You know what,
you know what I'm saying?
You understand also good with a support is to subscribe on Itunes,
stitcher,
Google play and all these other podcasting providing platforms.
Not to mention youtube.
If you liked the video format,
you want to see what Jocko looks like.
If you don't know already.
Uh,
you know,
I guess you can see what I looked like,
which I'm not saying to look at me to look at me because if you don't know what
echo looks like,
go look on Youtube.
You can see what it looks like cause he doesn't look like what you think he
looks like apparently.
Yeah.
Apparently evidence,
I've known him too long to understand the,
what he appears to be via his voice.
Sure.
But apparently he doesn't sound like what he looks like,
so yeah,
you guys might want to check that out.
Yeah,
I guess they don't match my look and my voice,
apparently not.
But you know,
I live in a world where we're judged on the content of our character and the
contents of our hearts.
So,
oh,
I look doesn't matter quite as much as one might think,
but if you are less interested in seeing that go to youtube while you're at it,
subscribe.
That's a good way to support.
Plus we're going to,
we do add other videos that are shorter in form.
We do have the video version and podcasts,
whole thing,
two hours,
three hours,
however long and echo is going to post a video of,
I think it's the most I've laughed,
uh,
captured on video and history.
So I was laughing at something that,
that was not in the podcast we were recording wasn't in the podcast.
I laughed.
It was really hard.
Is Pre podcasting pre podcast record sesh.
Sure.
And that happened.
So I'm looking forward to seeing that one.
You better get it up before this thing comes up
anyway.
Yeah.
Anyway,
that's a good way to support subscribe,
Youtube,
other ex ex small excerpts on there.
Anywhere from one minute to 12 minutes was the exception.
Usually it's between one and three minutes.
Little blessings that you can kind of straddle.
The one that thinks 12 minutes is an excerpt.
I Dunno.
I don't think that's right.
Technically it is.
Yeah,
I'd guess it is,
but technically less.
Make them three minutes.
Okay.
You got it.
You should.
You should put more effort into them and,
and,
and cut them down like the real critical parts.
That's what I think.
Okay.
Thank you for that out on the effort that at all.
No,
no,
no.
All good.
Thank you.
Wreck your method.
No,
I'm going to try flank.
Hey,
you know what?
I think they're good,
but you think they'd be go over better if they were even a little bit shorter.
We think in the long ones.
Really pro with this stuff.
I'm just kind of over here.
See,
you got whatever you need.
You're the man.
But nonetheless,
that's a good way to support.
So you can make the excerpt 17 minutes long.
Yeah.
But maybe there's 17 minutes of complete beauty value.
Yeah,
exactly.
Right.
Also,
Jocko has a store,
it's called Jocko store,
Jacqueline [inaudible] dot com that's the website.
So anyway on there,
there's what t shirts,
travel mugs,
some bumper stickers on there,
some patches.
These are velcro patches.
You can interchange them.
They're cool.
They wound up being pretty cool.
Yeah,
I agree.
Yeah.
Guys that are deployed.
Representing those overseas.
Yeah.
It's so cool too.
Um,
it's,
it's weird because
you know,
like you always say like we're sitting in this room,
and sure we've got some patches out there,
but to see him likable,
but you know,
they'll post it on social and they'll send it to you and they'll tag and stuff
like that.
And to see him like Dang,
guys are rolling around,
straight up representing.
It's like,
it's weird.
It's,
it's,
we're in a good way.
Yeah.
No,
it's awesome.
Yeah,
it's super awesome to see hope.
So yeah,
there's some stuff on there.
Hey,
just got the docker store.com that's the website.
And Hey,
if you like what you see,
if you like an item,
get an item.
Good way to support also on your journey.
We all,
no matter what Jocko will ever say,
we all hit moments of weakness.
And just like if you're going to Max Bench,
I know I said this before,
I'm a say it again because it holds true.
If you're going to go one rep max or even to write Max whatever on bench.
What about three rep max,
three Rep Max as well.
It starts to get a little bit more safe I think in my opinion,
but let's say two rep backs,
you're going to have someone there to spot you just in case you fully intend to
get those two reps fully,
but when you're pushing it,
it's wise to have a spot because if for some reason maybe you didn't eat your,
you know a good whatever,
maybe didn't get enough sleep,
I don't know,
but you could hit a little roadblock.
Little moment of weakness.
You have that spot there,
boom gets do through,
get to that last inch on your rep or whatever keeps you on your path.
This is the real world version of this is called psychological warfare and what
that is.
It's an album with tracks,
Jocko tracks and for any situation you might find yourself in that you have a
moment of weakness like getting up in the morning or skipping your workout when
you intended to work out or slacking on your diet.
Jocko will be there with a track that'll help you through it.
It's called psychological warfare.
Jocko Willink.
Do a search,
iTunes,
Amazon music,
other MP3,
providing,
what do you call it?
Outlets.
Yeah,
that's a good one.
Real good on.
Cool.
Also,
you know we've got,
we've got kind of a kind of a big announcement coming,
which we haven't really had any big announcements,
right?
I'm not a big,
you know what,
I'm not a big announcement kind of guy.
Right.
Plus,
so I guess I'm not going to do this whole thing.
The big amounts of things.
I
will,
I will say this.
This is it.
Okay.
Just we'll say we're not going to hold back.
This is what's going on.
After many months of due diligence and conversations and relationship building
and growing understanding,
we are actually joining forces
with
a company called origin
origin,
Brazilian Jujitsu
in Maine.
Now this actually occurred,
believe it or not do to this podcast,
this podcast,
I was doing a Facebook live.
I said something about,
this was months ago,
said something about origin day.
If you want to Geek giggy from origin,
they make them in America.
They're well crafted,
special material woven up in Maine.
They're cool.
Check 'em out.
And Sarah Armstrong,
you know Sarah,
I'm sorry.
Of course they do.
She motivated,
got after it and put me in touch with this guy p Roberts,
who's the founder and owner of origin.
And you know,
I knew about them.
That's why I was talking about them on the Facebook live cause I,
cause I had seen him and I had known that like a,
uh,
like a possessed psychopath.
He wanted to make cheese in America.
So we went and found looms to weave material with that,
all that stuff.
And He,
and the thing is,
is he was basically alone with his team on his quest to make this happen.
But the cool thing is he's not alone anymore.
He has a partner now.
In fact,
it is partners.
Now me,
you,
and,
and really all of us to help out,
to get in the game with what we're doing now and,
and just say no origin.
Like I said,
it's not some brand that's throwing some graphics onto a tee shirt,
right?
That's not,
well,
that's not what's going on there.
You have a legitimate movement,
for lack of a better word,
of a guy that is up there.
And what we're trying to do is read,
read,
rebirth manufacturing in America.
So that's it started with geese.
Um,
that's definitely a huge focus.
But we're going to make everything,
we're going to build the best gear in the world,
not just for Jujitsu,
but for everything you do in life.
We're going to make the best gear for being on the warpath.
That's what we're going to do.
So we'll come out with a bunch of details.
That's the big announcement that was going to come.
I just made it.
So,
Hey,
and you know what?
In the meantime,
a checkout origin,
main.com for geese,
for rash guards,
for whatever else you might need.
And if you want to see what this is all about,
by the way,
if you want to see what we're going to do,
come up to the camp that we're having with digit to camp up in Maine.
Echo's going to be there.
I'm going to be there.
A bunch of black belts are going to be there.
We're going to be getting after it or cruising or both.
It's August 20th through the 27th two sessions are going to be their echo and I
are going to be there the last day of the first session in the first day of the
second session.
So that's when we're going to be up there.
And people been asking what level of Jujitsu do you need to be?
You can be any level if you've never done it before.
That's cool.
Calm oil,
teach you,
we'll give you the base.
I will give you the basic,
that thing that echo talked about earlier.
Um,
but so of you've never done it.
Come learn.
It'll be the best introduction you're ever going to get in your life.
Quite frankly.
Just to come and train immersion for either four days or seven days.
That's a,
it's a good way to start learning the language,
get immersed in it.
And,
and by the way also if you're a black belt or a brown belt or a purple belt and
you want to come up and just train hard core with a bunch of good dudes,
come on up.
So that's that also,
this is cool on the 23rd of August,
so in the middle of that camp there is,
we are opening,
opening a new factory,
20,000 square feet of American manufacturing in Farmington,
Maine.
Uh,
come on up.
It's actually open to the public.
So come on up,
hang out.
We're going to be there,
you know,
doing what we do,
cruising,
checking now.
And it's going to be,
it's like pretty historical in my mind.
This merging of bad,
bad ass Nis come into fruition after many months behind the scenes.
Um,
so yeah,
come and join us on that day.
The 23rd,
even if you're not the camp,
come on up.
Uh,
you know what else we're going to have at the camp Jocko white tea they get,
we have plenty of it.
So,
uh,
you,
if you,
if you're not coming to camp and you want to talk a white tea,
you can go get it on Amazon.
If you're,
if you're sick and tired of dead lifting less than 8,000 pounds,
order some immediately.
Also weigh the warrior kid.
And thank you for all this awesome feedback that everyone's been giving me of
kids getting stronger and faster and smarter and better.
That's awesome.
So if you have a kid or you know,
a kid get him or her,
this book,
and by the way,
if you're wondering,
well to war your kid is that for girls,
believe me.
Well,
what is your girl think of it after does it doesn't matter.
So they need it.
We all need it.
So get one for yourself as as well.
There's lessons for everybody in there from Uncle Jake.
True.
Uh,
the other one got another book coming out and discipline equals freedom field
manual.
Now.
If you want a feel good book,
if you want a book that's going to fill you with a bunch of fantasies,
don't get this book book is not for you.
This book is real.
This book is going to hit you hard and if you don't want to get hit hard,
then don't order it.
If you want to be coddled,
don't get this book.
If you want to be lied to,
don't get this book,
but if you want the truth,
Andy,
if you want to get stronger,
faster,
smarter and better,
then yes,
go ahead and order this book.
Order it from your local bookstore.
Go into them and say,
ah,
you know,
can I order this book?
And when you get it in,
can you just put it in the get after its section for me so I can find it?
So discipline equals freedom field manual.
Order it online,
Barnes and nobles,
Amazon,
your local bookstore.
Put the word out.
Of course,
you can also get extreme ownership.
Ownership is a key word there.
And I recommend you own it.
Get that book,
own it yourself and get it your team.
The copies as well so that you can go out and annihilate your enemy or your
competitor who,
whoever's offering you.
We also have echelon,
front leadership consulting.
No one else can do what we do.
And I'm saying that right now and the reason I'm saying that now it's cause
we've been doing it long enough and I've seen what other people do from a
leadership perspective and consulting.
No one else can do what we do.
So if you need leadership alignment so your team can win,
you got me Leif,
JP,
Dave,
it's our company.
Don't book us through a Speaker's agent.
Don't book us through our online book agent.
Go to Asheville on front.com or email info@echelonfront.com and finally the
monster,
the next monster,
September 14th and 15th in San Diego.
This is kind of crazy.
We've already sold more than half the tickets,
so this is absolutely going to sell out.
Just like it sold out the first time in San Diego,
just like it sold out in New York City.
Just like it sold out in Austin,
Texas.
Don't get left out in the cold.
Get registered extreme ownership.com come and come and get it.
And while you're waiting for the immersion camp or while you're waiting for the
monster,
we're not hard to find because we're rolling on the interwebs kind of hard,
actually extra hard,
something we're on Twitter.
Sure.
The Instagram and dad,
VC boy
echo is at Echo Charles and I am at Jocko Willink.
And finally,
thanks to everyone that makes this podcast possible.
First and foremost,
our military who keeps us free to create and grow and live the way we want to
live.
Thanks to you all for holding the line and thanks also to police,
law enforcement,
firefighters,
paramedics and other first responders.
Thank you all for making this podcast possible.
Yeah,
by keeping us safe here on the home front.
So thanks to you all as well.
And finally to everyone else out there,
whether you're going through good times or bad times,
whether you're winning the game or you're making a comeback,
whether you're building a house or a road,
or a bridge,
or a piece of software,
whether you're assembling a car or assembling a meeting,
or if you're in a diner,
pouring a cup of coffee for someone that's about to go out and pour concrete,
whether you're sowing seeds in a field
or sewing the stitches into a geek,
no matter what you're doing
and what you come up against,
fight hard.
Okay.
Do it with everything you've got and no matter what,
never quit.
And always,
yeah,
always
keep getting after it.
So until next time,
this is echo and Jocko out.